the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
hello everyone this is Juan's
Grandmaster Sabina Foster and I'm joined
by a national Master Julian perlaco
great to see to have you back Julian and
we're here with the final round of the
San Luis super Swiss tournament let's
take a look at the results from last
night
so yesterday
was a quite a tough round for everyone
but there were quite a number of draws
Christopher you was able to save his
game against Darry Schwartz maintaining
his lead with five and a half on board
two Grandmaster Raja harshit Drew
against Nicolas deodorum both players
with five and a half
um board 3 was also drawn between
vasector Bailey and mihailan tipos
Brandon Jacobson won against Grandmaster
Lazar brazon putting him that is Brandon
Jacobson with five and a half as well
sharing First Place Grand Master yasar
Casada won his game against Costa
kabutsky Ileana
Drew against VAR akobian
won his game against gleb dudin
grandma grandma won against
International Master Josiah stillerman
Irene tsukandar suffered a defeat
against Brian Escalante
and Grandmaster Balaji dagupati won
against Maria Malika and Evan Park
suffered a defeat against Grandmaster
Fidel Corrales
here's the second page of those results
that you guys can see it's a really
tough tournament but I think
a lot of the players are possibly some
of them are excited going into the last
round and others
yeah for sure very tough tournament uh
let's take a look at the standings
because there are a lot of players tied
at first place I believe there are five
players right now a tie it at five and a
half and uh Nicholas theodoru has taken
a buy
um to play for the St Louis archbishops
in the Pro chess league so he will end
the tournament on Six Points the other
players
um still fighting to try to achieve six
and a half and definitely the top the
top two boards are are the ones to watch
out for today
so the um the tournament format is game
uh game 90 with a 30 second increment
starting from move one it's a nine round
Swiss tournament uh
which means that uh the people within
score groups play each other
um yeah so but last round we're into the
last round today is the day the round
started at 11 A.M we're getting in the
transmission of the moves can't wait to
get started on looking
um at the games but we want to say that
we're thankful for you being with us all
this week long for the live commentary
of the super Swiss event don't forget
that you can replay the games on lead
chess and you can follow us on YouTube
and twitch and feel free to interact
with us in the chat and if you prefer to
use a hashtag about the event feel free
to do so using the hashtag STL super
Swiss thank you so much for being here
and welcome everyone
let's get into today's uh yeah let's see
yes let's take a look
so it's Brandon Jacobson on board one
against Yasser quesada Perez on board
two it is Christopher you against Raja
harshit
um and those are our five and a half but
don't forget about the people on Five
Points because if uh boards one and two
make a draw then those players will have
a chance to tie for first place so
elshon more to your body on board three
against Daria Schwartz by the way what a
match up on board three Daria Schwartz
was in the sinkfield cup and elshon was
in the US Championship it's it's uh it's
a really tough tournament into those
types of players it is for sure you know
in a few years back actually was the
coach of the men's team in the world
team championship 2019 and he was the
coach and darrish was playing in that
team so that's that's kind of a lot of a
lot of history between us too for sure
uh yeah and uh Brian Escalante versus
durabai and amihail and teepoff against
Aram hakobian and that finishes off our
players that could possibly tie for
first
all right so let's go into the stage two
Age Two and uh yeah it seems like as you
said you know Nicolas deodori is playing
for the Sun lyrics
team the protest League he's doing well
and you were checking you're checking
some of those games before we went to
live
um it's it's going to be interesting to
see if any of the the other players the
the other four players are going to be
able to have a decisive result to take
home
this tournament or if they're going to
draw and then some people with five
points are gonna catch up yeah I'm torn
because on the one hand I want to see
decisive chess on the other hand you
know I'm really thankful that Theodora
can play for our team so I wanted to
type her first also I understand so I
guess let's get into the games let's get
into the game analysis of some of these
players start with board one
we already received some moves so
hopefully there will be no technical
difficult abilities for this final round
Brendan Jacobson had the white has the
white pieces against Yasser
quesada Perez and what was this of
course everyone's going for the Catalan
these days very trendy it's becoming
more and more trendy for some reason and
there are various lines you can play
this being the main one of course
but Bishop E7 was Black's Choice Bishop
G2 Castle Knight C3 and C6 Knight C3 is
very interesting actually so there's
there's a lot of move order subtleties
in the Catalan but um if you play the
move castles then the main move is D
takes C C4 and then here white usually
plays Queen C2 but there's an old an
older line I think which is 95 and
um here black plays the move Knight C6
yeah and the argument is if we go back
to the position after Knights or sorry
actually so Knight C6 Bishop C6 you take
a whole bunch and then there's a bunch
of theory here that eventually leads to
some equal position probably would take
yeah take take Queen A4 or C2 probably
A4 is more accurate than E5 try to get
the pawn back
um It's actually kind of inconvenient
that white is already castled because
your light scores are sort of weak but
if you play Knight C3 instead of castles
um the point is if black plays DC4 here
and you play the move Knight E5 the
Knight C6 is an inferior move and white
white argues that this is like an
improvement
because you didn't cast them and you can
somehow keep the camera you can play
Queen A4 here and yeah now now E5 you
just take it and take on C4 and you're
more or less just up a pawn for very
little compensation you might be able to
even cast along I don't know this
position
um for white but
yeah maybe you keep thinking in the
center maybe sometimes they play F3 king
of two even yeah this this line is very
fun for white I I've played this a few
times myself
nice capturing in C4 regardless of what
kind of move or the right place
um I've tried it a couple of times times
myself I know C6 is the other option
that you can play whether you know it is
be Forecastle or after so the whole
point is in the Catalan if you have this
idea that you want to play C5 and give
yourself more space you can't do it too
soon because I think there are some
lines where white ends up capturing here
and then you'll remain with an isolated
Pawn if you take there will be a capture
this is more like a tarash basically so
you know it transposes into a tarsh and
I think white usually has a more like
easier position than
um
then black does sorry about that
okay
so but anyways C6 was played here and
then Castle
A5 so this is the current position A5 is
actually interesting I lost the game
very badly myself but it was not
I think I played B6 here and then my
opponent played Queen D3 and then some
E4 happened I showed that
in one of my
in one of my previous streams
A5 is this move that you're wondering
about Julian in the other game like what
is going on with that move it's always
this mysterious A5 yeah here makes a
little more sense to me because it seems
like DC4 will be stronger in a lot more
lines and B3 is a lot more likely to be
played but certainly mysterious in a lot
of positions different sometimes you're
you're trying to kind of secure this
before Square in a way and you're
waiting it's like a nice waiting move
that doesn't weaken your chain of Pawns
just yet so now for example if I plays
B3 I guess you would play B6 but you're
just waiting to see where the screen is
going to be placed
um and um
and you're waiting with the development
of that this position reminds me a lot
more of like a queen's Indian than a
Catalan to be honest with you it gives
me those sorts of
Vibes yeah
but the bishop is in G2 so is that going
to be affecting black at some point here
or not we'll have to wait and see
the moves we've received so far are
until here and seems like Brendan is
thinking if the times are correct he may
have been surprised by this move because
he's been spending quite some time on it
but
let's hope it's not uh technical
issue yeah you know you never know these
days I mean I mean it's uh there's a lot
of things going on here in San Luis by
the way for those of you who are joining
us just now and you're not familiar with
this we want to let you know that
tomorrow the American Cup is starting so
that's going to be an amazing tournament
um
that's an element eliminatory tournament
and it has an interesting format
they're going to be 16 players taking
part in it eight in the male Section
Eight in the female section and there's
going to be commentary by
your
okay I'm told I'm told I'm told I should
say the overall section I apologize
about that uh the commentary team is
formed by the awesome
uh Grandmasters Christian kirilla Yasser
sarawan and international Master huskaya
Yovan Castle I hope you guys will be
live for that will be joining us live
for that event starting tomorrow too so
lots of things going on here there's no
rest day
um there's no risk for even some of the
players so that's players have played in
both the super Swiss and uh and are
going to play in the American Cup like
Alice Lee yeah and she's playing in the
purchase League this morning as well so
she's busy
she's definitely not having much rest
um hopefully you guys will choose pick
your favorite and you'll be watching
that event as well but uh Julian let's
go on to see what's happening in on
board two because Christopher you has
been also one of the lead leaders of the
event he's still leading and he's
playing against Grandma's Grandmaster
Raja harshit and they also decided to
play a Catalan I want luckily
there's a change here so we cannot say
that one of the players is looking at
how bored what's happening on board two
actually that that happened to me one
time someone was telling me that
um they were playing this game and um
next to them
um they were the the people were kind of
repeating there was like a strong player
on one of the boards playing with the
white pieces and the strong player with
the black pieces of the weaker players
with the opposite colors they were kind
of copying what was happening on the
other board and I think one of those
strong players went to the tournament
director and asked to be moved because
they didn't want they didn't want a risk
of um so this literally happened to me
so so I I was playing Grandmaster
Vladimir boulouse and I had a student
who was playing at 2100. okay my student
was like 2 000 at the time and I we're
both plain white and my opponent is
Grandmaster Vladimir belush so I expect
to get crushed which I did and and my
student's opponent was looking at my
opponent's board just to see what moves
he was going to play I was like I don't
care if I lose but like this 2100
shouldn't be playing like Vladimir will
lose right so it went to the tournament
director I was like can you move them
and they're like I don't know so finally
did they move them so what what
eventually happened was my student
figured out that I was going to get
crushed and just decided to deviate
which I think I said which was smart of
him okay also that student's name was
Arjun so shout out to Arjun okay
nice that's a nice story I don't think
it's happened to me uh that that that
happened
um
so I guess
that's good I wouldn't want I wouldn't
want to have to go to the tournament
director or the the Arbiter and tell
them about this you don't really like to
complain I complain anyways after the
game on my own so that people don't need
to hear me being unhappy about something
so this was an interesting choice by
Raja harshit because he played Bishop B4
check attracting Bishop D2 which he
believes might not be the right
placement for the bishop and now he
doesn't go into those lines with you
know A5 or anything like that but he
goes back Bishop to E7 right this is the
line that I play and then Bishop G2 and
then supposedly this bishop is not very
well placed eventually it will happen
yeah so so like the big idea of this is
if we start with Bishop E7 instead of
Bishop B4
um
and white plays Bishop G2 and we castle
and they castle if we play the move C6
then white has the option of playing
Queen C2 followed by Knight D2 and then
E4 really fast yeah
um and if you don't take
um if you play Bishop before check first
and they put their Bishop on D2 it seems
like we're wasting a Tempo because we
put Bishop B4 to E7 but White's gonna
have to waste the tempo moving their
Bishop out of the way in that position
so we actually gain the tempo because it
was here and yeah and even if they do
play Knight C3 and queen C2 in that
position
here so after cast of Castle C6 C2
something even if they play Knight C3 I
think E4 push might still be an issue
also is this an option so I actually
played the move Knight D7 instead of B6
just a preference thing because if you
play the Moon Knight C3 here then taking
on C4 is a lot more reasonable because
you have also that option to protect or
maybe B5 and then Newton wasted time
with these things
it's yeah move orders are important you
have to kind of think about them when
when you're deciding to play in Grand
Masters kind of spend a lot of time
deciding that I've noticed from various
people that I got the chance to ask how
they do with their preparation what what
is it that they what is it that they do
um okay
let's
let's move on to the game which was B6
Bishop G5 so Christopher did move his
bishop and now he's going to be delayed
from playing E4 so let's see here after
93. it's actually very interesting that
Christopher chose the Catalan because I
don't really think of Christopher as a
D4 player much less a Catalan player I
think of Christopher as like an E4
player where he plays like a lot of
sharp stuff and and like gambits and
that kind of thing so this is definitely
an unusual choice for him
this is um this is interesting now Raja
harshit
has been asked the question is he going
to play Bishop A6 is he going to stick
to the normal lines with Bishop B7 and
just wait for I don't know if these
ideas with E4 are still things that you
want to do immediately with white you
probably want to prepare it with Rook D1
first
yeah
um it's also curious so I'm sure there's
an immediate refutation to this but what
is wrong with the move D take C4 for
instance I guess no yeah I guess Knight
D2 is his point
and now C6 and C4 are hanging
yeah because you played B6 so
he has to give up one of those usually
this is the one you give up
I suppose white has a more pleasant
position after Knight takes C4
these pieces seem more active
yeah and black is going to struggle to
push this Pawn I think a lot of the
times in the cattle and I've noticed
people playing B3 Bishop B2 but I think
with a bishop here what gets to be
annoying a little bit is the fact that
this bishop can get to F4 so whenever
you think you're ready to go Rook C8 and
maybe Queen C7 or something or even Rook
C7 and then get your queen away from
there even Queen A8 and then Rook C8
you're going to have to deal with this
move Bishop F4 which would be unpleasant
so black might have ideas with
potentially trying to trade that Bishop
by going maybe Knight D5
yeah I mean D6 could end up being very
weak
um if it does it does the bishop also
Bishops on the board
I agree
so maybe this could work because we
don't have
I mean is this an option
uh probably not right yeah I think the
Knight gets trapped yeah queensy oh even
Queen B8 I guess I mean maybe not it's
not over it's not over until it's over
but
um
I think that night will end up being
trapped you have maybe wait but okay
actually so okay instead of Queen B8 can
we go Queen Seven because I know I'm
blundering my D5 Pawn but like so like
Knight takes uh he takes and then Bishop
takes but Queen takes B7 I don't think
you should get enough here Lake Bishop
takes C6 Queen C7
I might just end up up a piece
yeah I'll have two pawns but that's not
sufficient right
should not be sufficient actually you
might be in danger of losing another
piece here if you're not careful right
yeah yeah I should take with the queen
but that's no fun yeah yeah this is not
this is definitely not something that
white wants to get into but this is the
current position that we have at the
moment and
um should we should we move on to the
next board as we're waiting for more
moves sure
oh this it looks like this looks very
very scary yeah I don't know what's
happening so I'll show one for E4 I was
oh I'm I'm Amazed by this I I thought he
was mostly playing D4 but I guess you
always learn new things
um so he does play he does playing for
as well shouldn't you know I should know
I should know as he plays I didn't know
he was going for uh this this E4 I
thought he was gonna go for D4 I guess
he's in uh fighting mode he's I mean if
he wins he
catches up with some of the people
depending what's happening on for sports
obviously this is kind of a you know an
important for him in your mind when
somebody plays E4 is that like an
indication they want to fight or is an
indication that they don't want to fight
because to me when I when I play E4 is
because I want to make a draw really
yeah when I play D4 I'm trying to beat
you when I play E4 I want to trade all
the pieces and make a draw
I think it depends because some players
are all around like aggressive players
and I would feel that E4 is the kind of
repertoire that's more aggressive than
D4
there's a lot more lines in my opinion
but I could be wrong with D4 where you
can just set a position that's going to
lead to a potential drawers
for E4 I think you have more aggressive
ideas
but that's just my opinion I mean it's
probably because I'm a D4 player and I
tend to believe that I'm more of a
positional strategic player rather than
attacking one every single time I try to
be
aggressive in a tag I probably over
extended my position and I ended up
losing it or something both yeah I mean
I've had a brilliant win one time with
E4 that was totally unexpected and that
was in the U.S Women's Championship few
years back where
um where I had the bad tournament and I
was playing against uh you know
a-time Women's Champion U.S women's
champion Irina crush and
um
I just wanted to play something that she
wasn't prepared again so I just prepared
E4 the whole morning and that's it
that's all the preparation that I did
and she was playing the Sicilian so we
kind of reviewed all the Sicilians and
then I ended up winning that game
against the Sicilian which it was just
kind of lucky I was I was winning a
first I messed up the opening of course
I did because I wasn't filming there
were some things and then
um
it happened that
I was totally winning around 140 and I
messed up so I had to start my winnings
Improvement it was a Queensland game
Queen Pawn versus queen and it was
supposed to be a draw but somehow I was
able to win 100 something most 50
something most was that was that like a
was that a record in the U.S Women's
Championship it could have been it could
have been I know the Arbiters were not
happy about it because Arbiters are
never happy when you go over here the
game lasted so long and I I knew I was I
felt that I should have been winning I
just couldn't tell and everyone after
that was giving me a hard time that how
could you not see this move it's so easy
why would you even let her promote you
know all this stuff everything is really
easy when you're on the site and you
look you know and the engine tells you
the answer right right after after a
certain number of hours of play and you
don't know how much time went into the
preparation and everything
you just don't know you just don't know
how to to deal with things but anyways
um so that's the only time that I played
E4 and I don't even know if I really
wanted to win or how it was exactly but
I can tell you that it was totally out
of
the ordinary for me so I don't know
maybe I'll do it again but you
definitely I feel that you'll swear
Irena Crush
yeah I mean I you know it is stuff she's
she still uh has a lot of extra points
in in our matches we've met so many
times and she's a good friend so and it
was my teammate for so many years I mean
I was her tea makers she's still in the
team I'm not but anyways let's get back
to this game and see so elshon went for
um this E4 and he decided to go into the
CaRu Khan okay short variation yeah
um C4 Knight to six
uh okay D4 Queen B3 I guess this is
shell Theory but this could potentially
be a new move that's Knight E3 I see a
lot of moves here continue with Rook D1
so what are his ideas with Knight E3
here going maybe 596. yeah it seems like
a pretty serious threat like black needs
to respond to this right now so I guess
black is choosing between things like D3
and Knight G6
um because you just can't like if white
moves again and white plays the move
Knight B5 I think white is winning
mm-hmm
um so which one of this moves moves is
going to be more unpleasant and I wonder
after D3 is it possible it might be five
anyway yeah
I just don't think I don't think
this I mean we could sack the queen
yeah I don't I don't know these these
sorts of positions
could be like pretty good for white even
like the king's pretty weak and you're
kind of underdeveloped and B7 is hanging
yeah that's not I don't quite trust it
what about this
yeah so the question is like is this
position down a piece like worth
anything so like rookie one I guess you
continue you just play down a piece you
could take an F7 as well but I don't
think
it's necessary for Roy to rush this
night is very unpleasant there because
you can take him B7 yeah he also I was
thinking after Knight F7 black would
play King C7 and B7 is now like defended
so if you play rookie one there's no
there's no issue whereas if we had our
Knight on D6 in this position like we
play rookie one can C7 we could take on
B7 with with the queen which would be
highly unpleasant for black right when
uh so if you play King C7 here
yeah that was yeah it became over yeah
yeah so the king would have to stay
there a little bit longer we can develop
this bishop to G5 grab this Pawn come on
Knight c7's just a knight of seven is
just a threat right yep
for sure
I would I
I do like my night there I'm not so sure
I want to move it just yet I would
rather just keep it a little bit longer
potentially it feels like we have enough
for the piece right like the position
looks pretty good for us at least from a
practical standpoint dealing with these
problems with black cannot be super easy
I agree it's definitely a little bit
scary here
but let's see what about if we place
Knight G6 to try to get this pawn and
now if you play Knight B5 we'll take an
E5
I think if you play well okay I'm a
little I'm always scared to take the
pawn on E5 because uh yeah but um well
there's Bishops Bishop C5 I I always
want to do but I don't know it's never
super clear to me these positions
uh I play the Cairo but I never played
this line it was way too sharp for me
couldn't handle it I never understood
when you know Grand Masters play both E4
and D4 I never understood based on what
they they decide which one which move to
go with I don't know if in the chat
anyone said was suggesting that D4 was
more aggressive or E4 was more
aggressive Did anyone say anything about
that let us let us know in chat although
I have a suspicion that chat will say
that E4 is more aggressive because we
said that too so maybe they just agree
with us leading the witness or we're
just starting a fight about this I don't
know okay we can we can start some
fights over E4 and D4 it seems like
Knight G6 was played
um in this position and
I do not know anything about what Elston
has prepared in this position I actually
do want to cheat a little bit and see
what is the evaluation of this position
it says that black is slightly better C4
someone in the child is like C4 okay
none of the above Knight F3 Knight F3
because you can you can transpose into
more things okay
okay we're being trolled uh so yeah
actually I'm curious now that we have
the engine on after
um instead of Knight G6 if black plays
Knight D3 was RP sacrifice any good
probably not is that oh no Knight B5 is
nowhere
96 check
oh sorry so king da because we said that
that wasn't good okay rookie one yep yep
big Advantage for right in this position
we got something right that's right
that's good but it said also that
um
Rook D1 was an interesting choice here
as well we didn't go back to double
check if that was forcing
I assumed it was fine to bring the
Knight to D6 because it's so unpleasant
to have so many underdeveloped pieces
and the king in the center that you
should move with tall play would you
play Rook D1 or would he play an ip5
definitely be fine oh yeah for sure
um but here night what the engine says
Rook D1 or Knight B5 both of them allow
the capturing of the pawn here and Rook
D1 is anyways a move that's going to be
played so the question is and there were
a couple of games played in this
position
I'm pretty balanced it it does give a
little bit of advantage to black but I
feel that it's black needs to find F6 or
he's much worse
which I mean is thematic but at the same
time like castling seems so natural
well after F6 you are allowing to get
into this position which I don't know
yeah you need to evaluate this properly
but okay I guess it's up to up to
schwirtz and elshon to navigate those
roads properly and we'll have to wait
and see and try not to get nervous for
any of one of them
um
let's go on to board four
um so Brian Escalante is also and vasive
they're both on Five Points I believe as
well if we can pull up the
standings one more time yeah they are on
Five Points they're on Five Points yeah
for sure
and T buff
Five Five Points so if one of these
players wins they have a good chance of
tying for first place
um because boards one and two uh
everybody there is super strong and it's
very likely those games will end in a
draw yes until board five we we have to
stay mostly on those five boards because
most likely one of those players is
going to be the winner of this event and
uh depending on the results on the first
two boards of course
um if you were to take a guess right now
as to who's going to win the tournament
who do you think uh that would be
I don't know maybe
maybe they would uh they would share
first I feel like there would be lots of
draws some first two boards and then
everyone is going to share maybe one two
wins on board for him
three and four and five and then I've
just learned there are no playoffs if
there's a tie which is just highly
unfortunate yeah but you know that's
interesting that's interesting so I've
I've heard I've heard people say
different things about these playoffs
um sometimes I think for the fans those
playoffs are amazing because they get to
to root even more for their favorites
but then sometimes for the commentators
it's an extra work I personally and you
know I would have I would love to to do
commentary for playoffs I wouldn't mind
it I would I would be excited about it
but I know sometimes you know it's it is
you might think it's fun and all just
doing commentary but you are trying to
think of the best possible moves each
time and when you're not using the
engine you're you know trying to
calculate fast and bring all the action
to to the viewers so yeah I can
understand commentators who sometimes
say oh no playoffs but personally
personally I'm all in for playoffs yeah
when they are there it's like I think of
the commentators
well next time if you hear a commentator
who is not excited in doing that hire us
we'll be it's we'll be happy to I really
I want to see playoff between like
anybody who wins this tournament it
would be crazy
everybody in this tournament crazy
strong if they make it to playoffs that
would be super exciting I mean there
were so many Grandmasters that were
playing in this tournament and
um they had some decisive games against
each other they had some tough games
sometimes they were saves
um and um
yeah the grueling I guess comes to an
end after this round
for them but
um yeah we still have we still have this
round so let's let's enjoy it while it's
last E4 game I think yes
this is our first Sicilian the first
Sicilian of the day the animal is acara
so let's see
okay
it should be the naidorf bishop
so I started looking into this a little
bit but I don't think I'll ever play it
I'm too scared I need to I need to be
less fearful at some point so for those
of you who played the night of one thing
I learned myself and I'm happy to share
I'm sure you might know a little bit
more Julian but against this move and
this move you don't go for E5 that's one
thing so if you're learning the night or
don't go for E5 if white plays one of
those two moves true I did it a couple
times on stream and I lost well I was
lost probably I was able to Swindle my
opponents but that's something to
remember that you don't play E5 in this
line you can go for a five in fact the
whole point of the A6 it might be a
worth pointing uh like point out the
reason why yes so if you play Bishop G5
E5 is an inferior move to E6 because the
Knight is pinned on F6 and the D5 square
is super weak
um yeah something like Knight F5 even
Knight of five strong and the point is
that now with the Knight here if you go
Bishop E7 to uncut to untie yourself
yeah you can just yeah probably lots of
things went but Knight G7 anything wins
anything should win so you cannot do
that in this case yeah
um and uh against Bishop C4 if you go
for E5 this bishop is typically
open and again you allow this move and
the bishop has control over the square
so depending on what move order you're
playing with black you could play E5 or
not if you want to play E5 you probably
should go for other yeah move orders
it's important understanding the
downside of E5 and the downside is it
weakens the D5 Square pretty
significantly yes and both Bishop G5 and
Bishop C4 are aimed at the D5 Square so
E5 is not to be recommended against
those moves all right yeah
that hopefully summarized the reasons
and you guys can look more into it
if you want to play that night or it's
uh gonna take you quite some time to
memorize all this lines so good luck
good luck
Bishop V6
all right so capture in E6 was the
choice I thought Bishop B3 was more
natural but maybe black is going to get
ready to play D5 eventually Maybe
I don't know castle Yeah I think in this
line black most like I'm sure Bishop B3
yeah I think black mostly tries to like
occupy the C4 square with like his
Knight eventually so you like Castle go
97 uh Rook C8 B5 Knight B6 Knight C4 if
you get all that and you're pretty happy
but obviously white is going to try to
stop you from doing of course and
there's pressure here and then you know
it takes some time I think sometimes A4
might be in a move as well for why to
stop you from right
putting the queen in D3 to protect E4
coming on the default so anyways but
this is reminiscent of my game against
the arena just that I had a queen here
and I was able to go and attack her Pawn
oh that seems pretty cool I know
I wish I could do that right now I know
just just I wish this move existed you
could just one time in the game you
could just take any piece from wherever
it was and place it
wherever you wanted and then you know
that would be great but yep we played a
different kind of game we'll we'll
invent another variant where that would
be possible but for the moment we have
to stick to chess
chess rules queen of three Knight C6
oh he brought it there oh look okay yeah
you're predicted
he just you know
brought the queen I mean that's weak
right so anytime you see some piece
that's uh that happens to be weak
um well not a piece a pawn that happens
to be weak in the opponent's territory
especially if it's double it's always if
it's double pawns it's always the one
behind that tends to be
weak it's just not easy to attack it but
this is a nice uh this is yeah I mean
maneuvering once you said Queen h3o is
all about queenish there's like I don't
know how I want to do it but I want to
do it well he did it he seems to have
done it as well so Queen H3 went back
but okay now black has managed to defend
and somehow he will try to find a way to
chase you away though you might not need
to leave considering that that pawn will
be pinned so black will have to Castle
too and
try to
make your night go away definitely long
Castle which Brian has played here
age six and now Bishop B6 I like this
move Bishop B6 because there's no threat
on the Knight like I said already and
now he's just trying to make sure he's
somehow stabilizing a little bit the the
pawn structure
you're also threatening Bishop takes d8
here right yeah I think so I think so
you want to take and then this Pawn is
weak
looks like there were quite a number of
games that were played in this line so
it might still be in theory Castle
Bishop takes and now you have to take
the Knight so
it makes sense right I mean if you take
the bishop on d8 then I don't even know
where the witch piece is yeah yeah
you're gonna lose an exchange
yeah if you take the bishop I guess if
you take with the bishop then like Queen
takes E6 Queen takes E6 Knight takes E6
this looks pretty bad very bad for black
yeah I mean positionally you're worse
and also you're down upon yep so why has
the pawn and the compensation
so he he took in G5 which makes sense
Bishop takes E7 Queen takes C7 and now
he's he's going for that pawn so we got
a few weaknesses for black here E6 I
wouldn't consider this a weakness
anymore because it seems impossible for
white to reach it so that's why I've
highlighted the other pawns okay we can
you know leave those as red because they
might be weak but unreachable but these
two pawns G5 and and D6 are weak and
reachable
um this move however might not be
possible because I'm Knight G4 and then
black gets to attack F2 as well white
will have to find the right way to get
the screen back into the game without
allowing
some kind of Knight G4 so maybe Queen D3
at some point and then f3h4 yeah so I
see on your screen that like uh in this
position white has scored like quite
poorly black is winning a lot of games
but after Queen G3 yeah intuitively that
doesn't make a lot of sense to me
because like I like White's position it
seems like white
um doesn't have a lot of weaknesses and
black does so I would definitely prefer
to play White here if if I had to choose
a side yeah I think the the problem is
that if you could do whatever you wanted
with white from a positional standpoint
if this position was totally statical I
think white was definitely much better
I would simply go Queen G3 like I said
and then H4 or F3 first if I needed
Queen G3 and H4 but I feel that black
has some ideas too if if this queen gets
to be moved from here there's Knight H5
Knight coming to F4 uh when you go H4 I
want to play G4 to keep the H file close
so I think
you still have to consider tactics and
calculate things it's not totally up to
just white to do whatever they wanted
and then of course black has to put some
pressure on the side of the board
probably about rook and C8 pushing these
pawns forward I'm thinking yeah I I
don't know if that's the worst place
piece per white is definitely the Knight
on C3 I think you think the Knight I
think the queen is very annoying here at
this point
well I mean the queen can change like
pretty easily but I don't sorry I
shouldn't say the worst place piece the
worst piece on the board like if we were
to trade Knights right now I think white
would be much better much much better
whereas like if we trade Queens do I
really think that helps white I mean
maybe because D6 becomes weaker but I
would be happier about a nitrate I think
I agree if that would be possible yeah
that could be good
floor white it's going to be hard though
to imagine how that night is going to be
traded however
yeah so it's a rooted to us play to
protect F2 so that he can move his Queen
and
um and get to play H4 I think that's the
reason so B5 of course black has to
hurry
Queen D3 with Tempo and now B4 was
playing tonight
94. I guess it doesn't matter now in ig4
because we're protected so we can just
move the queen yeah maybe to B6
maybe that's smart here yeah I want to
take your D6 pawn and I also want to
keep an eye on the F2 Pawn you know I'm
not sure
not sure it's going to give up some
pawns here
would it be too much yeah I mean I will
try I will take your D6 Pawn you take D6
not the A6 I thought you'd go for A6
I just want to I want to see what you're
giving me some counter play here okay
for sure so I know you're getting some
off the pawns but yeah like Ricky Ricky
six
oh yeah Knight E3 actually maybe this is
yeah not yet I also have this one point
yeah this is complicated for sure you
should play 93 right away though because
if you don't then I'll play Knight D5
like in that position yeah yeah I saw
that move that was unpleasant
here
yeah definitely black black has some
ideas too he does but you know you can
actually you can still play here you can
still play yeah now you got some pieces
hanging so you have to go back and that
end game again has to be evaluated more
in depth but B4 was played here not
Knight G4 I feel by the way in that line
that I suggested I feel that way I could
take here first unless this is scary the
reason why I wasn't so sure was I
thought that uh yeah you might try the
move B4 and then just Rook a back and
take my a21
and uh
I wasn't I wasn't 100 convinced I was
doing okay there I think Knight G4 is
scary
it is very scary yeah maybe Queen G3 you
know maybe maybe this is just an
attraction kind of move and then he
keeps the Queen close by because now if
you go for example Rook F4 will play H
or F3 chasing that Knight back and and
then you have to go to age six or else
we could capture you might even try H4
here H4 directly because then I block so
you don't have them oh sure right
I mean if we could win on the H file
that would be that would be nice I agree
so this is a little bit this is a little
bit scary
um okay so B4 was played Knight to D1 to
protect here but this move is gonna stop
this road from coming into play yeah I
think Knight D1 is the most natural move
because you don't want to play Knight B1
that would be a problem no I was
thinking maybe 94 and beat me and just
kind of keeping things that's that's
true but it also like
um the night from D1 can go to E3
whereas like the knight's future on A4 I
mean I guess it can go to B6 and C4
later but
yeah I don't know maybe it was more of a
choice
okay so let's see
this game
has changed has changed quite a lot now
black has the center but those pawns are
hanging and potentially weak this Knight
can come to play this way there's
obviously a threat which white decided
to stop with Queen G6 and the question
is how do you stop the knight from being
brought to the attack we also have these
ideas and we also have these ideas I
have so many ideas for white I need to
start thinking for my opponents
um you know that when you have a
position where pieces are not ready to
be traded you have the tendency to just
think about yourself what you want to do
it's I think it's a human thing where we
are thinking used to sign your your
wanting to play chess you're like yes
give me this position I want to play all
these moves let me add them yeah and
then the other side is like really
because I think black is so much better
in this position sure make your moves
yeah we flip the board then you're like
give me the black pieces I'll get them
somehow I'll figure it out I'm just a
little bit worried here for for white
because I I see this move that's that
scares me for a little bit I could
you know get scared easily but maybe I
don't know you have to go team B1
and now
yeah I think you do CBD TBD yeah I think
you do have to be a little concerned
about your Center here though with black
um make sure that you're not like Ricky
one doesn't come with F4 and some
undermining I would be I would be afraid
for both sides it is it's short to
evaluate for me this position
because you know after I played D4 I am
kind of restricting your knight here but
in the same time I'm weakening E5 indeed
because you know when you have hanging
pawns you don't want to push them
forward too much especially not like
this to give the opponent a chance to
block them so
[Music]
um
but there are also ideas like this that
come to mind and so many ideas for both
sides
yes remains an interesting game that
will will certainly spend
quite some time on luckily this is what
happens when uh like Brian Escalante
very strong International master I'm
sure he's trying to become a grand
master plays uh against somebody who's
26 35 and basically just wants to beat
him the black pieces Brian is quite
young too right he's or no I mean uh
he's he's probably like my age but yeah
I don't know if you consider that to be
all night I don't really anymore well
compared to me yeah this is Young but
okay
all right so let's let's catch up with
board five as well because this is
another important game for potential
catching up in the standing so we have
Grandmaster Michael antipov against our
um Grandmaster arm hakobian yeah four
number five to 2600 Grand Masters fight
each other Four Knights four nights and
age three wow wow this is this is
I feel that maybe this is just a
decision to get out of all kind of
theory because if I'm not mistaken
Grandma Sarah ramhakobian is pretty well
booked on a lot of things so maybe white
is just trying to get him out of his
knowledge and just play something I
think people have been doing everything
in the four nights like every single
move you can think of they play like
obviously D4 is or is no Bishop B4
Bishop B5 should be five is more common
I guess slightly but D4 is the one that
I see the most often I agree but uh so
Bishop B5 D4 but they also play A3
you know yeah that's um and G3 and G3
I've played I've played G3 before I
think they literally play Everything
Under the Sun in this four nice position
I think the main point with these H3 and
A3 move is you're hoping that black
plays something like Bishop C5 which
should not be advised because white will
have the trick Knight takes uh E5 yeah
and he controls that square so
yeah this should lead to I think a
better position for for white yeah at
least slightly and this is not the
Halloween Gambit that would be in this
one oh they also play the move Knight
takes E5
I forgot about that I totally forgot
about the Halloween game until one of my
opponent one of my students shows me
this and he's he's not very high rated
but he's gotten into Theory a little bit
and he tells me about the hello in
Gambit and I knew which one it was but I
kind of forgot and then he's like oh
your opponent just blundered Knight
takes E5 and then he's like no something
that this is the Halloween Gambit and I
was like all right right yeah that's
what I meant no by the way this morning
both of your statements might be correct
his opponent might have blundered and
this is also the Halloween game yeah so
we don't know we don't know but uh
um this is actually tricky because if
you if you run the engine what are you
gonna do uh Knight G6 and then this is
the best thing that you can do to go
with your pieces back I don't know I
don't know what color you would rather
get here white or black I mean in
classical to be honest I'd rather be
black I'm just greedy I want to I want
to have the pieces in Blitz though I
mean it's so much more fun to play White
and Blitz is it yeah do whatever this is
this is something I'm gonna do on
Halloween so let's wait we'll have to
wait a bunch of months until then but
listen yeah it's interesting but okay at
their level I'm pretty sure they would
not want to test this out right in the
final round when they have the chance to
catch up with the leaders and let's see
if our team can pull up the
uh price funds so that we can remind
everyone what the players are playing
for in this tournament
all right 25 000 is the price fund and
there are 20 prizes 6 000 goes to first
four thousand to Second three thousand
third two thousand for fourth and
fifteen hundred four fifth and so on you
guys can see the prices actually I
forgot to ask
um whether maybe we'll be told
whether the players share the prices if
they share I think they share them
right so they'll be added up and evenly
divided between the players which means
by the way that if somebody wins the
tournament clear first on boards uh one
one and two they could there could be
quite a difference between first and
second place it's not going to be six
thousand versus four thousand it'll be
six thousand verse you know four
thousand three thousand two thousand
fifteen hundred divided by uh divided by
four right yeah right so they will big
pay difference that's right so everyone
is I think
trying to do their best in the final
round it's always nice as well to finish
the tournament with a win if you could
that's whether he had a good or bad
tournament it's it's nice to finish on a
positive note but unfortunately it's not
gonna go for every player
um here so we'll have to wait and see
but let's catch up with this game yeah I
was gonna say something about this
position instead of D5 I think I
understand the point of H3 like if you
play um D4 uh with white instead of H3
right so then takes takes Bishop B4 and
then Knight C6 BC
um Bishop Bishop D3 castles
and then I believe it's so castles D5 uh
something something like this
no no castles for white D5 take take
white has this move Bishop G5 right but
if we like reverse the colors the colors
here if we go to the game what H3 is all
about is if black plays D5 which I
believe he has in the game yes he has
then we get the same the same thing but
Bishop G5 at the end of this line so now
white is playing with the black pieces
and black is playing with white pieces
but Bishop G5 is no longer going to be
possible so white just has like this
really nice Center that he can uh he can
try to use to his Advantage all right
it's very nice very uh show there
Juliana like that
and that's why you have to know your
move orders and you have to know
positions with both white and black
pieces even if you don't play those
things you kind of have to know them
because you don't know when it might
benefit you to get the position with the
reverse color that's going to be good
yeah I mean transposing those ideas is
almost more important than like just
knowing them
so this is the current position that the
players have
um
reached at Bishop D3 and okay
I prefer white in this position I think
White's doing quite well I don't know if
black will ever have some sacrificial
ideas in H3
I love this
yeah I like both the Bishops where they
are and I think that white would have a
huge Advantage if you give him like just
one more turn to play c44 so I'm
wondering what what it's going to do
about Knight B4 though that's the only I
was thinking B5 but I could it could be
too soon
the night before here so are we going
Bishop E4 here because then black it
looks like positionally bad to play F5
but I am trying to win your Bishop
but maybe it's not worth it like F5 then
I go back and then you've created like
this big weakness on E5 that I can try
to take advantage of long term maybe
this is the idea before yeah I actually
really like white here I think however
the black should play this one of B5 to
stop that although what's gonna it's
gonna happen if you still play it maybe
before yeah yeah
try to get rid of that pawn and then go
C4 this is going to be a deaf engine
interesting
fight for sure
all right well the position is here guys
we're gonna take a short break and we'll
be back stay close
I was like
launches in March for the second annual
American Cup world-class Chess Masters
will gather in the chess capital of
America St Louis Missouri to compete in
a double elimination tournament for a
combined three hundred thousand dollars
in prizes we will cover all the action
live from the World Chess Hall of Fame
from March 17th through March 26th tune
in for the best game in chess streaming
live for more information visit
uschesschamps.com
do
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
the St Louis chess club's 2023 chess
season launches in March for the second
annual American Cup world-class Chess
Masters will gather in the chess capital
of America St Louis Missouri to compete
in a double elimination tournament for a
combined 300 000 in prizes we will cover
all the action live from the World Chess
Hall of Fame from March 17th through
March 26th tune in for the best game in
chess streaming live for more
information visit uschesschamps.com
the St Louis chess club's 2023 chess
season launches in March for the second
annual American Cup world-class Chess
Masters will gather in the chess capital
of America St Louis Missouri to compete
in a double elimination tournament for a
combined 300 thousand dollars in prizes
we will cover all the action live from
the World Chess Hall of Fame from March
17th through March 26th tune in for the
best game in chess streaming live for
more information visit uschesschamps.com
the St Louis chess club's 2023 chess
season launches in March for the second
annual American Cup world-class Chess
Masters will gather in the chest capital
of America St Louis Missouri to compete
in a double elimination tournament for a
combined three hundred thousand dollars
in prizes we will cover all the action
live from the World Chess Hall of Fame
from March 17th through March 26th tune
in for the best game in chess streaming
live for more information visit
uschesschamps.com
the St Louis chess club's 2023 chess
season launches in March for the second
annual American Cup world-class Chess
Masters will gather in the chest capital
of America St Louis Missouri to compete
in a double elimination tournament for a
combined three hundred thousand dollars
in prizes we will cover all the action
live from the World Chess Hall of Fame
from March 17th through March 26th tune
in for the best game in chess streaming
live for more information visit
uschesschamps.com
the St Louis chess club's 2023 chess
season launches in March for the second
annual American Cup world-class Chess
Masters will gather in the chest capital
of America St Louis Missouri to compete
in a double elimination tournament for a
combined 300 000 in prizes we will cover
all the action live from the World Chess
Hall of Fame from March 17th through
March 26th tune in for the best game in
chess streaming live for more
information visit uschesschamps.com
the St Louis chess club's 2023 chess
season launches in March
[Music]
hi everyone we're back with the final
round in the San Luis super Swiss I'm
women's Grandmaster Sabina foyer I'm
National Master Julian perlaco and let's
get back into the action
of the final round if you guys remember
before went we went on break
we talked about the standings let's see
if you guys can remember who are the top
players the ones sharing first prizes
it's uh Yasser quesada Perez uh Chris
for you and Nicholas Theodore and
Brandon Jacobson going into this round
with five and a half point or sorry and
also Roger harshit going to the brown
with five and a half points
unfortunately or fortunately for St
Louis unfortunately for Theodore he had
to take a bite to play in the protest
league for us but we won so thank God he
did he pulled through
um so he will end the tournament on Six
Points the other players still have the
ability to uh achieve six and a half
points
um although maybe some of the games are
becoming a pretty pretty solid and
likely possible there will be draws and
then we will have a lot of winners for
this tournament
there's not going to be any playoff so
the players will share the prizes so for
this board board number one Brendan
Jacobson was playing against
yes sir
quesada Perez and we saw that they went
into a Catalan and then this we stopped
around here at this move A5 actually and
then rookie won 97 and in this position
after 92 as Brandon Jacobson was getting
ready to prepare for an E4
his move was met with E5 a very
interesting counter in the center that
seems to be giving up a pawn but I don't
think it does because black is taking
advantage of the fact that white moved
with the knight from protecting the pawn
the Knight also blocks the queen from
protecting D4 so now if you say oh I'm
winning a pawn with C takes D5 no you're
not
who's winning upon here yeah this is it
might be black no I think maybe we can
no we can not only go for this line
this would be
this is very messy it takes takes on D2
and E1 is hanging with check so you
don't have to yeah so you lose way too
much material way too much so you
definitely don't want to get into this
position so obviously after E5 white
somehow had to capture here but this
allows black
to get his night out open up the bishop
and now the fact that black didn't play
B6 can be a helpful tool because the
bishop will get out on this other side
of the board and he hasn't really
weakened he's
Queen side C takes D5
okay so black now has an isolated Pawn
but he has his Bishop open and I think
blacks development is slightly slightly
faster than whites yeah and also a lot
of pieces have been traded so a
continuous Knight of three takes takes
and
um Bishop B6 yeah
a lot of the pieces have been traded
which uh
usually benefits the side plane against
the isolated Pawn because the side with
the isolated Pawn wants to like attack
and Checkmate whereas the side without
it wants to Target the isolated pawn and
eventually win it so probably white is
slightly for Choice here if I had to
guess yeah and I also like the
white can play the smooth
before because now
trying attempting to trade one more
minor piece and if that's going to
happen all white has to do at least in
theories triple on the D file with the
two Rooks in front of the queen which is
also known to be as alikine's gun idea
the turoks and the queen last and then
preparing for a D4 taking advantage of a
potential pin on the D file as black
sets up their pieces to protect the
isolated pawn and then white is set to
win upon after which of course the game
still goes on but
um that's going to be a little bit
unpleasant for black so black will have
to defend yeah 4V 4v3s are usually
usually not losing if it's a pure Rook
end game but with the extra A and B
pawns on the board it definitely
provides white like extra winning
chances in those types of positions yeah
well we've seen yesterday at I think it
was Brandon Jacobson yesterday morning
where he saved a rook end game right so
he's used to those most likely with the
white or with the black pieces or with
the
disadvantage or the advantage but I
think he's definitely going to continue
pushing here although
black is going to try to find
some kind of Contra plan the queen side
potentially
because now you cannot go Rook C1
obviously right there's going to be a
capture
and you'll lose a piece or right yeah
it's it's checking you can't do one yeah
also yeah you've done a lot of it yeah I
just want to say that that's not a good
move clearly yeah so now with white we
need to think how we're going to
approach this position because black may
want to trade and get active on the
second rank to get some kind of activity
as I mentioned on the queen side in a
way or Rook C4 is also kind of
unpleasant
so how is white going to meet those
moves yeah the bishop takes D4 Rook C4 I
don't think B3 is something you want to
play Maybe Queen D3
yeah I'm not I'm not totally sure
the my first instinct was Queen D2 I'm
not I'm not sure why I think
yeah I think the reason was I was
attracted to the idea of playing
um like Bishop F6 and queen A5 at some
point but here it's not so good because
B2 is hanging at the end
but you have Rook B1 and B7 is hanging
too so but you don't want to make as you
mentioned earlier you don't want to make
trades of these Pawns in these types of
positions you typically want to have
those pawns later to kind of combine the
attack on the isolated pawn and then
either queen or King side attacks
typically they do a king side attack
uh create some more weaknesses on the
king side and then if black sets up the
best defense for the isolated Pawn
somehow in a lateral fashion it's going
to be difficult though here yeah what's
what's fun no this isn't like possible
at all in this type of position but I
found that that this type of position is
pretty good for um white if you can have
opposite Bishops like if you trade the
dark Square Bishop for the white square
Bishop like that's always super
unpleasant that's right I think there's
a famous casparov or carp of casparov
game where he ended up winning with some
attack on the king side in such a
position it's one of their games of the
match I'm terrible with remembering name
numbers of games maybe you know yeah
you're familiar I don't remember the
number of the game
I think I do know what you're talking
about though
but yeah certainly White's the one for
choice in this position I think
this is the
they try to avoid letting them double up
on the c-file
but right
I would play here if I were black
to force you to make up your mind
whether you'll trade or go E3 but if you
go E3 will trade and no more isolated
Pawn so you're kind of forced to capture
let's see what's happening in this
position
yeah so Queen B2 I guess Rook B1 is the
intention which Rook uh April I was
thinking a
the queen will have to go back somewhere
and then could we go even here maybe
I would be happy with black to trade a
couple more pieces take take B7 you want
Rook a8s were
some or a rookies to be careful I have
to be careful here because my back rank
is something I have to deal with I got a
pawn down right now I need to get it
back
yeah I guess the goal is to trade the
d-pawn for the a pawn and try to play
this 4v3 yeah this this move doesn't
actually have a threat I mean because
you know yeah yeah there's check and
then you put something back and then in
the end you're gonna lose that pawn and
white is definitely depressing here that
is for sure
[Music]
someone was asking exactly this line I
believe or something different when
Bishop takes F6 Queen takes F6
[Music]
yeah after Queen B2 that is possible but
I don't really like putting my pieces
like in touch like this like B6 now
needs to be calculated right
like you're the queen in the in the
bishop have a bad relationship you have
to stay there
but now you're in trouble
you might want to sacrifice the queen
for some pieces I don't know yeah yeah
it's tough uh plus I think in general if
you were to choose between winning the
D5 pawn and the B7 Pawn you would prefer
to win B7 because D5 should be a little
weaker yeah this and not just that
you're also creating a passport for
yourself so there's no point in in not
doing that first it makes more sense to
take this spawn first
so yeah
okay so we need to come up with
something different here for black but
uh
yeah I don't I don't know maybe maybe we
just your move Queen D2 by the way
because that was the one for
looking at maybe not Rook C4 for black
I mean obviously you have a thread I
thought going into that line was fine
because black was getting reader some
pieces he was trading off some pieces
but
giving up material doesn't seem to be
the right thing to do so we need to
change that a little bit maybe
maybe black can just play like H6 here
or something just solve his back rank
issues and then try to play the position
like if you this is the same as before
the same as before but now we don't have
the same back crank issues okay so here
and then if we're trying to make uh some
kind well let's say queen C2
um because my intention is to make Rook
B7 with Rook A8 you have Arc A7 here
uh but I can take maybe and then take
and go Queen D2 followed by
dt4 maybe yeah I saw that I I would
rather not give up a pawn unless I'm
forced to because this already puts you
in a slightly worse position and you
have to find the moves to get your palm
back and if you don't then you're
staying with material disadvantage that
is certain so unless it's forcing unless
we have nothing better to do I would
rather not give up that pawn I don't
think black is desperate to
to necessarily have to make that
decision
I also could technically just take here
if I wanted to right since you already
moved the queen and now I could go maybe
Rook C4 yeah so Queen D2 back I guess
yeah so but now at least you know I you
don't have pressure on my pawn and I can
try to come up with the way to get in my
Rook I did like your H6 idea obviously
I'll have to meet this Rook C1 with
something
um but okay that there was a move so I
guess the players saved us from this
difficult thinking process so
um Brendan decided to capture the
special this bishop in F6 Queen takes
and now probably he's thinking Queen G2
he might it might be more forcing than
the line we're thinking at
yeah no Queen B3 was his choice ah okay
okay this I don't like first of all you
know I know he's a Grandmaster and
everything
I'm allowed not to like some of his
moves hopefully yeah hopefully he will
not get you know
negativity for that but I like the queen
here because when you only have one
Bishop left you're supposed to place
your queen on the opposite color to
control more squares
but he's so intuitively I like really
hate putting my queen on the same
diagonal as my opponent's Bishops it
just like gives me this bad feeling you
know I know I know it's just really
surprised of his choice Queen to B3 here
Brandon has a very like combative style
and I'm sure that this is based more
around calculation than anything else
something that we missed for sure but I
don't know he's attracting black to go
D4 or something yeah I
I couldn't I couldn't say queen D2 is
that Queen B3 is definitely not a not
what what I would have done with the
position but
okay let's check it
um let's see what does the engine like
wow the engine actually likes Bishop
takes D5
which surprises me Queen D2 better than
Queen B3 by point one for now for now it
could change it could change in a couple
of seconds oh no no
one point one both point one that's
okay all right well he's got something
going on here but he Bishop takes D5 we
didn't consider that we didn't get the
chance to consider because I saw a move
was played so I was trying to catch up
with them yeah
but Bishop D5 so against Rook d8 we're
going e44
I guess uh which Rook though and then we
will have the isolated Pawn
yeah eventually but which Rook
probably the one in F right
in some situations there'll be a check
there that's what I was I was still not
sure it's obviously so what queen takes
or you want to do this first oh okay
sorry you don't want to do that I I
wasn't sure yeah I was thinking Queen
takes B2 first but actually no I like
your idea better because you're I guess
the point was if I do this you have Rook
B1 here and A2 is still defended whereas
if we had already traded A2 would not be
defended
uh everything you said just like came
together so the line is takes takes
Queen takes B2 Rook B1 Queen A2 then
Rook takes B7 Queen D5 and then finally
you show the points rookie eight see
that's what I'm saying you always have
to double check these things when it's
about bringing a rook so if we start
with the other Rook maybe we're like
super smart I mean you don't need to
make this move obviously yeah we could
play Rook takes D5 yeah but how good is
it is it it's really good
or is it just tricky good no yeah
that's your luck
they call it they call me a lux box what
can I say
trying to go on through some ways to get
to the background or here but obviously
you know the queen protects F7 so now
white is upon down I don't know what we
did with poor White's position come on
um what what's going on he just took a
pawn where where did those two pawns go
away that fast how did that happen yeah
so
okay what's so probably you have to play
something yeah you have to go I mean I'm
going there
okay so anyway I have to utilize that
pawn right as well as I can so we still
don't know which Rook is better and it's
always very hard because when you're in
a knowledge when you're doing analysis
you can always go back and be like oh
yeah I put the wrong Rook let me go back
and switch and we can have the exact
same line but when you play that's it
you made the move done if you chose the
wrong one
well that's your bad luck and you have
to deal with that and come up with
something better to improve the position
the best is when you're analyzing with
really strong players and they just like
change the Rook they don't yeah they
don't even tell you they're just like oh
you can't even tell them let's go back
by the way maybe I don't play this you
have to kind of go with the line and you
have to agree with what they said that
they were right and terrible yeah and
you got no choice you got no choice
that's why you need to keep analyzing so
that you improve your level and that way
they can't trick you with that so
of course I'm just kidding because a lot
of a lot of strong players when you
analyze with them I think are very nice
so you know it's fine to go back and
forth in fact that's how an analysis a
good analysis is really done when you
get the chance to
so we've looked at this game a lot do
you want to take a look at the uh the
other game yeah so let's see what
Christopher you
doing in his game against Raja harshid
this last we're quite behind around here
somewhere I think we saw this move and a
similar idea in both games this idea was
92 just here uh Christopher played this
move after black capture so now this E5
move is not a possibility like in the
Jacobson
um quesada game so here 92 trying to get
the pawn black is holding on to the C4
Pawn giving the C6 one
and
okay
an unusual move but kind of only move
probably in that position to keep the
bishop protected Bishop B2 and I think I
know this line I don't know why is there
Theory still here no but why would I
know this line
because I wouldn't know too many to
I wouldn't I don't play this line so
it's similar to something to something
there's some clothesline where this
happens but I don't yeah but the white
usually I think white takes there black
takes here and then there's a check or
something and then you take that and
it's possible that your queen gets
trapped there's a line
okay
yeah
but this is a little bit different so
now white has a threat of potentially
dropping that coin with
Rook D1 Bishop F4
or not now could you go here I mean it
probably it doesn't trap your queen but
it's probably pretty good for white
right
so
whether you trap the queen or not I
prefer white in that position
yeah
so black is retreating obviously you
don't want to trade with white because
this Knight is badly placed so a trade
would help black develop the Knight
Queen to C2 Knight takes
and F6 yeah it's actually F6 is an
important thing to talk about so
normally you don't want to play moves
like F6 weakening E6 but black custom
makes some sort of concession here
because if you take on G5 with the
bishop it could end up in a situation
where you play the move G6 and your dark
squares are pretty weak around your cane
and um F6 is the lesser of the two evils
probably is what he was thinking
yeah
he also is trying to keep more pieces on
the board as he's probably trying to get
a little bit more space advantage
um also because there's still a pony E2
you're not so worried about this Pawn
getting attacked anytime soon after
playing F6 because if this Pawn was gone
rookie one could come in Bishop H3
putting pressure this Knight is also not
on the right path to attack the pawn so
black and choose after F6 where they'll
go for F5 if needed or E5 more likely E5
but you know they still have to consider
the opening of this diagonal so it might
just be
okay so see so now if Bishop F4 I felt
that black was planning to go E5 yeah
you get something very similar in like
maroxy structures yes so this with
reverse colors yeah I I uh I don't mind
Black's position so much here in fact
maybe I prefer to play Black at this
point
so Christopher went back Bishop E3 and
now it is Black's turn to come up with
something well obviously black needs to
get this Knight back into play this
bishop might not be so well placed
anymore but he does have a majority on
the queen side so this pushes are gonna
happen eventually
mm-hmm
yeah he's a comments her by the name of
Hans name and says we don't know if it's
really Hans we don't know if it's
terrible for whom and also terrible for
who we we are not sure
but uh thanks for that let us know let
us know I mean don't just give us two
words just
develop that so that we can you know
maybe he doesn't like the setup of the
camera maybe that's what he's talking
about oh maybe a terrible position
yeah we need to ask our our team to come
fix this camera
um do you uh want to check out altron's
game yeah
I I think I appear black as you said
here too
um
but yeah all right I I don't like these
pieces and and these Pawn pushes will
happen eventually somehow the opponent
F6 is somehow nice right yeah it
restricts White's night at the moment
and it's hard to imagine a repositioning
of this night for for now one step five
will be played and black will happily
gladly trade the light Square Bishop so
the wise King will be weak and I'm
really thinking of that idea I was
mentioning a queen side attack first but
I don't know
[Music]
okay yeah let's uh let's catch up with
elshon's game we left it all changed
lots of strange so we left it off around
here and we were saying that black
should
um eventually find this plan with F6
which darish has found Bishop takes E5
Rook D1 this is why he's 26 46 I suppose
the problem speaks for itself we're told
that could be hunts or someone else
if it sounds High hands
um F6 e takes F6
Queen A4
so are we threatening Knight takes D4 I
think that's the point of Queen A4 yes
we are so if you play some random move
I think we can take
guys well that's the intermediate yeah
and yeah we're running upon so that's
the threat and so black played D5 which
could be a strengthening move or more of
an
weakening one in a way but I don't see
how white can get on the light squares
here
A3 with the idea oh oh now I see now I
see how it gets on that diagonal easy
easy peasy a3b4 chasing the bishop away
and then getting that diagonal for the
bishop what is black on a castle is the
question and the answer is given by in
Black's next move
there's king size and he's not worried
about B4 C5 I guess because the king is
going to hide there and he might want to
use the G file for a potential attack
I'm yeah I guess with White's last move
A3 it's like a little scarier to Castle
queenside because you don't want to
Castle into White's play with B4 if
White's gonna play B4 no matter what you
do why put your cane on that side of the
board right
but actually it's interesting because
black didn't get the chance to play A3
because of the pin so she's a little bit
behind with that I don't know if he
wasted any move anywhere I don't believe
so but now white gets this before in and
then he will have to be mindful about
his Knight because very soon black will
have the threat of playing A3 and the
Knight is kind of trapped there
in B5 that's the problem luckily Knight
C3 is still an option due to the PIN
but he has to be mindful for that move
not to not to be something he forgets
about like yeah I mean the Knight could
just get trapped at some point yeah
that could be true it looks nice but you
need to be you need to be cautious about
some things so Bishop H6 was the move
played by elshon in this position and
darush is thinking
of course when we play C5 we'll have the
opportunity to place the knight in D6
which of course will be
kind of nice
yeah so
where do we put the Rook yeah I don't
think it's F7 I I was thinking here
right so the reason why you didn't want
to go to F7 was because C5 Bishop C4 was
something that concerned you I suppose
yeah uh no I also wanted to keep this
Rook protected in case I wanted to play
A6 if I play here I don't have this
thread because I'll always be pinned
um I don't think black should
necessarily be super concerned about
this because he does have oh he well
that's debatable
yeah I mean it's very concrete and
obviously it's a threat here it's not
necessarily it means it's going to be a
threat in every position
that is true actually can black afford
to give up an exchange because that's
another option that he would have here
that would be that would be something
yeah you could you could get some very
strong attack maybe like take take the
Knight F4 at some point
but we have 93 yeah I don't I don't
really believe in it right now but if
you can't bring your knight back to C3
and you get Knight F4 it could
definitely be very scary mm-hmm
um I I'm sure you've seen these attacks
before where like black uh I don't know
how a sample variation would go but
maybe something like k h a take take
then
um like Rook C1 or something the Knight
F4 and then Bishop F1 and and then you
go like yeah like Rook G8 and Bishop H3
like this sort of thing works a lot in
Blitz and bullet that's right yeah
that's true yeah those those could be
very unpleasant if they were to happen
someone someone is asking in the chat if
Hikaru is playing so
today we are looking at the final round
of the San Luis super Swiss this is the
game that's going to decide the winner
of the tournament starting tomorrow at
1pm Central Time
the American Cup is going to start so
that's the tournament where you're going
to see Hikaru back
playing over the board and you can find
out more information about the event on
our website
sandwiches Club but also u.schess
champs.com
and of course follow the action lives
both here on Twitch and YouTube
those that tournament is going to be
broadcasted live from our studio with
awesome commentary by
the wonderful Christian carrilla yes or
sarawan and Ivanka Ivanka Huska so I
really hope you guys get the chance to
join us tomorrow for that event but
until then we still have a very strong
tournament taking place here in San Luis
the super Swiss one that we've been
going over for the past few days
and yeah the final round
looks like
darush play drug f2d8 that was the move
that we considered first there was
played
so he was probably worried about keeping
the Rook there not having the option to
bring it on the G file later this way
that Rook after King h8 will be able to
go to G8 yeah so makes makes a lot of
sense
yeah I'm I'm actually pretty happy with
Black's position right now um I know it
seems like a little scary because like
what black skin seems a little open but
after teenage Rook G8 I think there's
there's just going to be a lot of
positions where where White's cane will
end up a lot a lot more scared than
black skin
I agree let's let's go on to the next
game that was also a very interesting
board four lots of things happened since
we last saw this position I think we
stopped around this move Knight to D1
where white was retreating with the
Knight and we were saying there are some
ideas we saw D5 being played and the
capture of the pawn and then Queen E6
I think actually we were a little bit
ahead with our last
last time we saw the position so here
black decided to start pushing the a
pawn and creating some weaknesses around
White's King
um while white still has to figure out
how to attack Black's King
there's no easy way to open up it would
take quite a number of moves to actually
open up a file so white may have to
focus
on these hanging ponds as Jacob uh
Julian mentioned earlier I'm sorry uh
rookie won and and F4 that was an idea
that you mentioned that I really liked
for white so A5 rookie one Rook d8 okay
there was a threat of the pawn so black
defended it with that truck which is
interesting because you think that could
help you with some attack but probably
vasif was thinking well I'll go at 483
and then white will play B3 the position
will be closed there so my Rook is not
gonna be very helpful so I better keep
this Rook for defense and potential who
knows night move and attack F2 or defend
here like this and just bring this other
Rook yeah and now black probably has a
thread right which is uh E4 like a
position and then E3 no just just two
64. just E4 to gain like space in the
center and then maybe like improve
position with Queen E5 which is why
white decided to play F3 here to stop to
stop all that from happening I think I
don't know unless you have some tactical
solution
um
but it seems like that's why he was
probably played yeah no I I think you're
right I think that's definitely
something that black was considering
playing here yes you played some silly
move like H3 then E4 would be I think
good for good for black
and then black would play Queen E5 or D5
next centralizing the queen
yeah I mean just this queen has been cut
off from all these other pieces and
there's no way to get them into play any
pawn pushes would allow other Palm
pushes for black and and white is
totally restricted here I'm starting to
like black quite a lot in this game
F3 to stop E4 and now he's bringing the
Knight okay you mentioned earlier that
you would love to get the knights Trader
because out of all of White's pieces
that was the worst yeah
yeah I think maybe it's still the same
but yeah I know I I mean if he gets to
play here and trade the knights and then
get the Rook on e4 you start you know
having some attacking ideas yourself but
what you have to be mindful about is
obviously this A3
oh he chose B3 even better yeah I was
thinking A3 and then trying to get the
queen in here which maybe was not his
choice because he thought white could
easily stop a queen entrance through C3
yeah I think that also looks pretty
scary to be honest with you but I guess
he was worried the B4 would be weak like
later like maybe B3 Knight D3 comes true
before it could end up being but I mean
I I have a serious serious answer it's
very I'm giving up everything just to
meet you but maybe yeah
um you can take by the way here and and
say oh I'm defending oops
and you don't have sufficient time to go
rookie seven and meet me in G7 so
obviously this is a serious thread that
has to be met with something this
could be a solution oh yeah we can't
take because of this and wait can I wait
hold up can we go back one second sorry
um if I play a move like this seems
crazy I know but what about Rook D6
so the intention yeah in case of a trade
we want to yeah
most people want them and you might be
thinking King C1 whatever because Queen
B2 can do one but Queen A1 is checkmate
you cannot Escape that it's interesting
um obviously I won't take oops I'm sorry
yeah you'd have to play something else
but I want to play Knight takes E4 next
and queen C3 stealing all of your ideas
sealing all your Amazing Ideas I know
it's hard well I'll take it I'll I'll
come back yeah
that's fair
um
probably with this Rook right yeah
and then or maybe the other one to bring
the room but yeah I mean I I guess with
B3 you're keeping more options opened of
of weakening white skin compared to this
there's just one idea okay but I
actually really like black here I think
Queen C3 might be really strong actually
you know if you oh okay like Queen C3
Queen takes then D takes uh D takes with
the point being that if you
um like this type of position seems
really bad with the King cut like Rook
D5
um even even Rook D2 or Rook D2 yeah
everything looks really strong for black
I was actually thinking about this other
idea after the takes if takes with the
rook and after Queen D3 I was thinking
maybe this was an option but then the
spawn is potentially hanging so it might
not be I mean maybe it's still good
no I don't think so even this moves oh
Ricky for you yeah
fortunate
so it could have been an alternative to
the attack getting this these moves in
maybe white wasn't gonna play B3 and
just stay there but then capture okay
eight
yeah I mean you this is all like a
timing thing maybe white is just in time
to play the move Knight D3 and Rook
takes E5 and generate his own initiative
[Music]
could be that's what he was afraid of
that's why that's why he chose to play
B3 instead and white responded with A3
but now B takes C2 and
yeah white skin feels weak right yeah
much weaker than blacks it's earlier I
felt that black skin was going to be the
one attacked first but in this situation
it might seem that black is the one
taking taking control over things yeah
those 2600 Grand Masters were like yeah
White's doing great and then a few years
later you're like wait a second actually
you're making a lot of good points with
the black pieces maybe Queen takes is an
option in this position but
I prefer black I still prefer black well
maybe you can defend
I wonder how much material I can afford
to give up actually if you want to give
up why why you're not you're
not I always wanted to give away the A4
Pawn so
there but then I realized
that actually Rick CA might be pretty
bad because Roxy at Queen A4 it's not
that you're losing the A4 Pawn it's that
like Rook takes D4 and more importantly
Rook a queen takes D4 is something that
we really need to watch out for
well we have an in-between move if we
want to do black but there's no need for
that I really think when tc2 has to be
played here by white oh why did he
played The Rook takes it yeah maybe
maybe why he's trying to get activated
he's trying to get on Seventh rank so
for example if you go for Queen B3 white
could attempt Rook C7
and you know
white has his own ideas too
well he can't do it yet I'm not sure how
yeah like Rick takes Rook takes D7 and
then maybe like end games have to be
good for us now right now that like the
pawns are all blockaded so maybe we can
even play the move like Queen C2 or
something
um and just yeah it's sort of going back
but like
if you play Queen takes C2 King takes C2
I actually think that end game is a
little more pleasant for white just
because Knight D3 is coming and like the
center might not be a strength anymore
it might just be a weakness
yeah I agree that's
that could be a thing too I was thinking
more to keep the Queens on the board to
have some attacking ideas still with
pressure on E5 since you don't have a
thread just yet some Knight H6 check
um obviously we need to calculate what's
happening after Rook B8 if we really
have anything after this check or not we
might not have much and we'll have to
just defend
which is not going to be that easy I
think in in every given position though
I just want to trade queens and you
always want to keep Queens on the board
yeah but of course all trade queens and
lose a pawn for nothing it's fine and
you'll keep Queens on the boards depends
upon it's also fine it
into situations so Rook C2 Queen B3 and
then
um
black played Queen D6 so I guess he
wants to stab that he has the queen
defended right now to off off the pin
and rugby eight and queen takes A3 might
be something to consider as well as the
E3 as a threat that black has in this
position do you want to go 94 or yeah so
I was going to ask do we still want to
trade Knights because we can do it on
the other hand like the Knight on D3
looks pretty good like instead of this
right
yeah putting pressure there instead but
you have to think whether black will
have the opportunity to bring in more
pressure like I said with Rook here for
sure and queen takes a three yeah
because like now like Rook takes E5 if
you take on A3 like B2 is temporarily
defended so I I do have this option of
Rook C7 I don't know how strong maybe
maybe it's really very strong I think
it's very strong yeah 98 I even have a
rookie eight so yeah this this Rook is
is great here
it's interesting the position is spicing
up a little bit people are like fighting
today everybody is very combative that's
great to see right yes for sure the
final round oh yeah a lot of blood is
about to be spilled
yep on top boards and as we told
everyone the time control for this
tournament was 1 hour 30 with 30 seconds
increment and that was it no second time
control
30 seconds additional time is all they
got and you know the games
get to be very interesting also
especially towards the end when people
don't have sufficient time and they
might be more prone to mistake Stakes
even you know
strong players like Grandmasters that we
see here on top boards let's catch up
with this final well not final but board
five that
um
are also on Five Points and with the win
depending on what's happening on the
first two boards they could catch up
with the leaders and share first place
potentially or just get a better place
in the standings so what ended up
happening with this uh
yeah and you were mentioning that what
is going to happen if black was gonna go
for the bishop and looks like black
listened to you okay listened uh not
good news for him not real not real
listening but uh but why didn't I go for
Bishop E4 to try to attract a five seems
like white did not really care in a way
about the bishop and just went for C4
yeah I think the worst way you can cheat
in chess is listen to me
what I think about a position you can't
do any worse than that
don't say that but now people are people
the games are coming with a delay that's
why I was saying yeah you know they
listened to you yeah they you you kind
of
um anticipated that that move was better
and then or something I don't know what
I was gonna say let's get back to the
game not to get into
Hot Topics
through Queen takes D3 and now
Queen F6 yeah so the the argument here
between the two players is uh what's
better space and activity or two Bishops
because white definitely has like the
better like Place minor pieces at the
moment I believe like the bishop on C8
isn't like super well placed but the
Knight on F3 the bishop mb2 both seem
pretty good and the center pawns both
seem pretty good the bishop on D6 is
good yeah
but
so
black can have us traditional will have
the opportunity to go
Queen G6 at some point Queen B3 is
probably aimed at the B5 idea right
this was enough
whoa that's crazy it's just it's just me
asking is was that an option so if I so
I take
oh what evil thing are you going to do
to me oh it doesn't work oh okay okay
wait after rookie eight after okay but
this idea this is an idea to look for
for sure this is an idea to look for you
know because I'm thinking if I had
somehow The Rook
you bring the queen
nah
uh so I want sacrifices you know because
I don't get to play them in my games
usually so I just I'm just looking for
them I guess it's worth pointing out
instead of Queen B3 if White had played
a worse move like Queen seat D2 sure D2
yeah your Bishop H3 is really strong
that probably just wins the game of
course because we take the Knight and
everything but in the other situation
to a of a queen F6 Queen B3 obviously
Bishop takes H3 if you would be so kind
to go there obviously black will have
some ideas even here I'm not sure if I
had some no I I would have some yeah
well I think we're ba is really strong
and just take B2
um
yeah and well the problem comes back and
then Bishop E6 and yeah yeah and then
takes yeah
um yeah and this like seems like a fake
line Queen D2 like it doesn't it won't
happen in a real game but what could
happen in a real game is you play them
with like rookie one and then your
opponent plays Bishop F5 and you're like
oh well I'll just move my queen to D2
and membership H3 comes in your set yeah
something like that something like that
is something that could happen so it's
an idea you definitely want to be on the
lookout for but Queen B3 was playing
rookie eight anyways that makes sense
try to get the Rook active since you
don't know whether you're gonna be able
to develop your Bishop yet
we have breaking news that Christopher
you and Raja harshit have drawn their
game let's see how the game finished
there
which which means by the way they both
have six points and nobody uh so that
means that theodoro Christopher you and
Roger harshit finished the tournament on
six points and potentially that's good
enough to tie for first it's all up to
Brandon Jacobson yeah and he asked her
quesada Perez right now we definitely
need to look at that game yeah
um we need to go back and stay on the
look for that game but we thought we
thought black was doing quite well in
this position
good news for us 0.1
yeah and luckily the the engine has
already analyzed this game so we can
just follow that and you'll get the best
commentary
um the most accurate ones better said
the best you're always getting because
you're here so thanks for being here
um Bishop H3
so apparently that was a mistake
we don't know why yeah I wish that the
engine wasn't automatically
um I I don't know if I can stop it if I
click this button oh take it out wait I
actually know how to do it so if you go
to these three these three lines here
um yeah you can disable it says enable
computer analysis if you disable that
yeah there you go that's how you know
it's still there oh yeah because it
doesn't if someone pressed if someone
pressed that no I think this is just for
the X range and if we want the extra
engine I think it if someone pressed it
then um
then yeah yeah and so important
unfortunate that's okay but we can
that's okay well we are not we have the
engine off so we just go by one move
that it says which is not sufficient by
the way
um it said F5 this was the book that I
was saying what he didn't go for it was
worried about this that's the follow-up
computer you can't just give us two
moves and then you let me figure out I
just came down here computer is mean it
makes you work I know I know would we
take
would we take and then bring in the
queen or something
to attract F3
mm-hmm
right
and then what's gonna happen to this
picture this looks like a very bad very
very bad Bishop
yeah I mean somehow we are up a pawn
right like yeah and it's just it just
felt like the pawn on the queen side
just seems
like it's extra and white doesn't have a
lot of compensation for it at the moment
I agree I agree I'm surprised F5 is
another Choice also he probably thought
this was a mistake black thought this
was a mistake just to kind of show you
guys how the game ended here Queen C6
probably he was thinking okay I can do
this but then this is they just repeated
the position or something yeah
so they just repeated the position like
this black not realizing that he
actually had he actually had F5 first so
that's how things yeah so I guess the
thing is is that Christopher you like
didn't like his position too much
because he's down a pawn right and Raja
is black against a high area player so
he's thinking draw is a good result but
I mean both players might live to regret
this decision because if there's a
result on the Brandon Jacobson board
there will be quite like a pay
difference between quite a lot yeah
depending on how many it could yeah it
could be like three thousand dollar
difference it could be something like
pretty pretty huge substantial
well
maybe we can get one of the players
interviewed we're waiting on our team to
let us know if we'll have any interviews
we hope to have some
we hope so we hope we'll have some our
team hopes so too so I felt there was a
sad message I don't know Sabina why are
you giving us extra work uh do you want
to look at the brands in caseado game
just yeah let's go back and see what's
going on in that game because they
didn't go for the trades Brendan didn't
go for the pawn in D5 he put his Queen
on a light square that we were
definitely
unhappy about but obviously if he's
gonna win this and he's going to see the
stream he's probably going to be unhappy
without a comment
um
but if he does win you know we'll find
out his thinking process about this and
maybe we'll have Jacob ready to ask
about a specific Queen B3 move yeah I
mean
also we're we're not saying that like in
a in a disrespectful way we're just like
surprised of Queen V3 right you know
yeah yeah it's very interesting to get
into the mind of Brandon like Queen B3
uh queen queen B3 over Queen D2 is not
something that I would have selected and
I want to know what he was like the
process yeah yeah the process of
thinking there because obviously you
know there are a lot of ideas that we
know we learn as
early as we start playing chess about
various things we should and should not
do and then as you get to be a stronger
player you learn to
eliminate the good things and the bad
things and then you realize that there
are a lot of exceptions and you have to
consider how the position is and
everything and
um yeah it would be great to to
understand his thinking process I mean
we might see it through his moves as
well here he brought the queen to B5
which obviously was with the similar
ideas the queen was doing in D2 maybe he
thought the queen was better placed
there the question is is he going to
trade Queens we know ideally that's not
something you want to do when you're
playing against an isolated Pawn also
not just that black did push the pawn
forward and typically
when you have an isolated Pawn you want
to push it Forward more because it's
going to make it more difficult for the
opponent to attack it because it
restricts as restricts the opponent
a little bit more and yeah I mean if you
think about it right with the pawn on D5
there are four squares you can put your
pieces but when the pawns on D4 they're
only three squares that you can put your
pieces
um so just from that perspective it's
more difficult to attack
limits your opponent's decision space
um but yeah I think we're going to go on
a short break before we resume a
commentary on this final and very
exciting round stay close
the St Louis chess club's 2023 chess
season launches in March for the second
annual American Cup world-class Chess
Masters will gather in the chest capital
of America St Louis Missouri to compete
in a double elimination tournament for a
combined three hundred thousand dollars
in prizes we will cover all the action
live from the World Chess Hall of Fame
from March 17th through March 26th tune
in for the best game in chess streaming
live for more information visit
uschesschamps.com
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
the St Louis chess club's 2023 chess
season launches in March for the second
annual American Cup world-class Chess
Masters will gather in the chess capital
of America St Louis Missouri to compete
in a double elimination tournament for a
combined three hundred thousand dollars
in prizes we will cover all the action
live from the World Chess Hall of Fame
from March 17th through March 26th tune
in for the best game in chess streaming
live for more information visit
uschesschamps.com
the St Louis chess club's 2023 chess
season launches in March for the second
annual American Cup world-class Chess
Masters will gather in the chess capital
of America St Louis Missouri to compete
in a double elimination tournament for a
combined three hundred thousand dollars
in prizes we will cover all the action
live from the World Chess Hall of Fame
from March 17th through March 26th tune
in for the best game in chess streaming
live for more information visit
uschesschamps.com
the St Louis chess club's 2023 chess
season launches in March for the second
annual American Cup world-class Chess
Masters will gather in the chess capital
of America St Louis Missouri to compete
in a double elimination tournament for a
combined three hundred thousand dollars
in prizes we will cover all the action
live from the World Chess Hall of Fame
from March 17th through March 26th tune
in for the best game in chess streaming
live for more information visit
uschesschamps.com
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the final round of the
San Luis super Swiss event
by my wonderful co-host a national
Master Julian polico great to be back we
had a
break where you guys were able to see a
presentation of the next tournament
that's starting here in San Luis the
American Cup a really awesome tournament
that hopefully you guys won't miss
tomorrow at 1pm central time but let's
get back to the action in our tournament
Julian because a couple of interesting
things have happened in this tournament
the first interesting thing is that
Brandon decided to trade Queens maybe
not so interesting because we're going
into an end game that could potentially
go for a draw and then we'll have
potentially a very very big tie for
first place
yeah or not I mean there's also there's
still some chances here for white I
suppose
um I mean D4 is still weak and I'm sure
that Brandon after Rook 81 his last move
is intending to play this position upon
up and press the position
um and you know that's what we're
rooting for as chess fans to see some
like a clear first winner so right now
we're definitely rooting for Brandon to
uh to pull this one off
it's going to be hard I think but um
can't we just no we probably cannot play
D3 just yet with black in this position
is black going to try to get the E-2
Pawn somehow
somehow yeah and you have to get it in
like a smart way right because if you're
not careful and you lose like your D and
uh your D pawn and I get active or
something or I might win your a pawn
then my winning chances go up probably
not down
right black has to be careful here a
little bit I don't know if this is even
an option to try to defend the pawn
I would rather stay a little bit more
active I see like I see a stupid trick
and uh so so if you go like Rook B4 and
I go Rook D2 and you play Rook d8 and I
can potentially play the move E4 yeah
you play opposite which you know seems
like it's very clever then I'll hit you
with Bishop F7
that would be unpleasant
yeah there's a potentially for decisive
games for white here after King takes I
mean black still has something going on
but it's still holding chances maybe but
after Rook B2 it's very convenient I
have rookie too otherwise yeah I would
not be playing for anything that's true
that's true black takes this Pawn they
should be fine but yeah this is a nice
idea for sure
um I I would rather not play it before
unless that was my only choice here
obviously D3 I don't think it works due
to E4 here and this Pawn
yeah that pawn is going to be lost if
this we can just capture so obviously
that's not an option for black so black
has to either put pressure on this Pawn
or go to before I think those are the
only two choices that I'm seeing but we
have to be also careful with the back
rank because for sure
it could be some discovery that
leads into that so for example if you do
this
should we capture with this probably
with this Rook
I'm a little bit nervous about about
this especially before what is going on
no no white could actually fall into
this trap so you can you can think
you're winning but be careful when
you're hanging your pieces because you
never know what intermediate move
can happen and then it's going to be
your opponent who takes the control over
the game so rookie 8 is an option that
black can play in this position it
should be it should be for sure probably
Bishop C4 here I don't know what you
think about that move
seems interesting right
um you know me I I just look for all the
stupid tricks so after Rook B4 Rook
takes D4 then A3 could be an idea for
white because like when you said tricks
I thought you were going to say that if
black plays D3 here in this position and
then this is another trick and then
takes takes if y takes with the Rook
white can set up this trap in case you
just happen to take here or recapture
and then in the end we got a mate that
is certainly my kind of trick
but uh obviously in this position white
can recapture with a pawn as well and
this is also kind of a trick now
obviously with black I don't think you
should trade you could probably go row
d8 this Pawn is still hanging and white
won't be able to defend both the a pawn
even if you push it in A4 there's Rook
A2 right it's not even clear if White's
the one playing for the win here yeah
because black would take potentially
this further away pawn and then they
would have the further away past spawn
with more chances right so this position
I think is going to go for a draw and we
might have a lot of people sharing first
place during the break we looked at a
couple of games or seemed like a lot of
uh changes happen from the point of view
of the evaluation for example in this
game between Grand Masters and Aram
hakobian we said that white was probably
a little bit more comfortable in the
position and I think we're right until
until black
may have allowed a few moves that I
think he shouldn't this C5 move was
played I always thought that black was
going to try to play B6 to stop it I
mean obviously you don't really stop it
because in case you capture capture then
this bishop opens up to the queen and
it's going to be a fork so you cannot
really take in C5 anyways
this queen is slightly badly placed
there yeah yeah it always makes me
worried when the bishop and the queen
are lined up like that I I always want
to have the bishop in that in that case
and and it is it's getting a little bit
scary here for black after C5 Bishop F4
D5 was played and here black went Queen
to G6 with the attempt of
having some attacking ideas with Bishop
takes H3 however after Bishop E5 that
move
is not possible because I think Knight
H4 yeah yeah that looks really good
everything is going to be captured here
this Pawn is protected and white should
stay should win a piece so Black's only
choice here was Bishop G5 but I don't
see why white couldn't just capture this
Pawn for example or that one as a matter
of fact both pawns are kind of hanging I
don't think your sacrificial ideas would
Bishop H3 really work I like Bishop take
C7 more just so that my queen still
defends H3 laterally I think Bishop C7
and there's nothing even even Knight
takes G5 first could be an idea and if
you take because the queen opens up to
protect H3 so now we can take in C7 this
is another option obviously we're going
into an opposite color Bishop position
it doesn't mean that it's going to be a
draw but white may want to keep the
Knight on the board and just take
directly because I don't think black is
is going anywhere just seems like an
extra Pawn for white and
much better position it's possible that
we'll have a win on this game for
me Highland now again we haven't paid a
lot of attention to is uh grabinski
against nishnik which which makes sense
because they both have four and a half
points and can't like really win the
tournament but it's like bizarre because
nishnik it was so strong like 26.99 at
some point and Aaron's obviously a
strong International master so it just
goes to show how strong this event we've
like have hardly paid attention to these
players I know we kind of focused on the
top boards because one of those players
could win the event so but it doesn't
mean that the others are not going to
play Fighting Chess no game has finished
yet and it's almost three hours a place
since they started at 11 A.M central
time so we don't see any results on the
top 10 boards oh boy doesn't besides
that run actually oh yeah or two
Christopher you during this game against
Roger harshit so they may share first
place but other than that the games are
still going on and music has two extra
pawns here and most likely
don't like Aaron's position at all I
think I think he's just busted only one
extra upon actually I said too by
mistake but it feels like two it feels
like even more than two yeah I mean this
is this is going to be a continuation
very soon maybe white is considering
just giving up the night for one of
those pawns and then trying to get H and
and F pawns but I don't think he has
enough time for that yeah it's
it's really interesting like seeing
these strong Grand Masters playing Black
in the last round against people that I
mean 2400 is obviously not a bad player
2400 is very strong and seeing how they
just like dismantle them is always
interesting to me
I mean yeah this this position let's
check out some of the other games too to
see the current positions for example
this game between Lazaro brazon and
Balaji dagupati
yeah brazon also was a former 2700
player even higher than nishnik at his
Peak
and again is like not even not even one
of the contenders to win the tournament
no and and this position is actually
very interesting with this Pawn in F6 it
seems like white is going to have
some kind of attacking ideas however he
would love to somehow get his Queen in
G6
so after the queen moves somewhere when
to move the bishop and then possibly
capturing in G4 or depending on where
you go say you go like let's just choose
a bad Square for for black I think we
have Bishop takes G4 and if you take
we'll have some nice mate here
yeah Bishop H5 Knight F7 and and mate so
obviously black has to be a little bit
cautious about the retreating of the
queen in this position maybe Queen F7 is
a yeah queen of sevens stood out to me
somehow but maybe we can be clever here
and insert the move C takes D5 because
you can't take my Bishop at the moment
due to Bishop E6 or whoa well actually I
said that and I thought it is
that it's possible that's possible yeah
maybe it is
maybe yes like F7 here yeah it's better
to be lucky than good sometimes I know I
know but there's another move there's
another defense for black here there's
Queen H7 but here F7 check right and
then I trade queens and go E7 oh even
yeah
this is nice just to show the line till
the end check bam
Queen comes inmates next moment right
okay so Queen F7 this is a nice move so
obviously black cannot take here let's
uh let's make a better move for black
because this is there's someone to have
a better move
yeah
no no what to do queen of seven was a
good good response but maybe well I feel
that this Pawn needs to be stopped or
else ideas with F7 are going to be very
very annoying
hmm
maybe a bishop C5 here from from White
and as I as I uh said that
um I realized that there's a result in
that game between Elia while Lilia with
the black pieces again and with white
Aaron grabinsky what happened
so what happened there so Aaron resigned
which which makes a lot of sense at the
end of the game there just really is no
hope for white that's who connected past
pawns are going to be too much after
Rook D3 He resigned resigned
definitely tough game
it's it's really unfortunate that like
you're in the score group of the four
and a halfs and then you meet ilionic
like this monster player it's well this
is crazy this is definitely one of the
strongest you know
super Swiss
tournament because I mean how many Grand
Masters were there I never really
counted them I think I must have been at
least 15 or 6 or 17 grand Masters in the
tournament and
um you know
a lot of the games were very sharp well
prepared although it was a grueling
schedule I would say because the players
had to play both in the morning and in
the afternoon we were usually doing
commentary only for the morning rounds
unless we occasionally brought up the
previous night's games so they played at
11AM and then at 5 pm
for five days and this is their final
round yeah I've been told that there
were apparently 16 Grandmasters okay so
you were very very close almost on the
nose
there
um but yeah I mean Ilya niznik on board
seven and uh or sorry on on board six
and then bruzzone on board seven a Kobe
and on board eight it's just
unbelievably strong I don't think I've
seen a stronger Swiss tournament to be
honest with you like even things like
spice cup it doesn't feel like top eight
boards look that strong but I don't know
and you mentioned Jacobian this is his
uh
current position against International
Master Costa garwoodsky and I'm trying
to figure out who is better in this
position I I think I prefer the white
Pieces Just the king feels a lot safer
and F7 looks weaker than F2 at the
moment and it's white to play
so yeah white may need to go back with
the bishop I think I don't believe C6
would work I think
you don't really want to allow this
check so the core I have to be wrong I
have a question instead of C6 can I get
away with something like
um D7 yeah queen queen D7 and then I I
want to run my cane so like King G2 and
then Queen E4 and then how stupid is it
H3 yeah it seems like awfully I wish I
had one of those tactical things where I
could check you and then maybe yeah
that's
that's only in studies that idea does
not work here not at the moment yeah
yeah Queen G6
but now maybe C6
and you have to be careful because like
I'm threatening Queen takes F7 in a lot
of positions and then C7 will come but
maybe you don't even or Bishop takes F7
and then of course yeah yeah that's
that's a better way to do it
certainly yeah I think Bishop F7 is like
a really strong threat right now 37 is
nice in this position let's come up with
a with a defense for black if we can
if only we could
whether I give you check a new one or
here it does not matter because still I
would Retreat any four and then you'd go
to H3 and you think you're safe there it
doesn't look
and why is Queen a white skin in H3 does
look pretty safe but you know in these
kinds of positions what usually happens
is
um sometimes we make a move like King
somewhere where you know your capture
doesn't happen with check and then we
have threats however here I don't
believe that's an option because
obviously you're not gonna make this
silly move to allow a mate yeah you're
going to capture with a bishop or maybe
even not capturing just go C6
and I don't see a follow-up for black
um maybe how bad is the pawn down
position so instead of this like instead
of King G7 can you we can play G4 and
play an opposite color Bishop end game
um and I don't know how good like can
maybe maybe a white winning chances here
are actually pretty good
depending on how white is going to
create his other past spawn
if he manages to win this which I feel
is very much doable because
yeah this will play a foreign I think
this white has big chances to win this
no we should not trade into this uh VAR
actually played C6 in that position okay
so this is the current position that we
have that's interesting I wonder what I
wonder what he saw after Queen D7
because obviously he saw something after
Queen D7 otherwise he would have done
this and tried to win win the game in
this way so he must have been afraid of
something in particular I think
what could it be
I mean we can always just protect right
um okay so we could do this
and then Bishop E7 so what's your your
so my intention was yeah
okay so now we need
you all right very mean I'm sorry he's
just trying to play the position
is always looking for mates yeah I think
he did it yeah I actually think the
White's in trouble now that's that's
tough it gets a little bit scary I don't
wanna I mean I guess you can play F3
here and save your life but you could
but obviously but for how long the wrong
direction
for how long are you saving yourself
here because
this idea is very unpleasant it's gonna
happen
one way or another that's true I do
think that
um concretely I should be okay like G4 I
can just take yeah luckily yeah luckily
you can take and you take with check
otherwise I had Queen H7 Queen C2 yeah
yeah
but I couldn't move my queen right now
somewhere
though
yeah maybe
about that Bond right if you uh it's
it's very fortunate for why the D4 is
hanging with a check because otherwise
maybe you could be in some trouble
yeah so I mean but yeah certainly black
is for Choice here and not white which
is not where we wanted to be even if
even if black is winning somehow we
should know that this is not the way to
go so that's another way to go yeah I
think you're probably right about that
Bishop E7 is really strong so is he
going to take a draw or no of course not
I don't even know if I asked that
question I think VAR is always playing
his games till the end whether it's
the last round or any round he's a
really big fighter and he's going to
utilize his
yeah I was saying like that the bishop
attacking F7 was important at the start
but I think that was just incorrect like
the C Pawn is the C Pawn looks pretty
good and unless you manage to blockade
it then but I should be able to it
should be five next yeah
because like now if you try Queen B7 we
can trade and I think black should be
able to make a draw here because we
didn't give up any pawn and even if we
lose this one I think we should be able
to create some kind of a fortress yeah
but I don't think we play Queen B7 right
away you know like you're just going to
have to stay around that pawn for a
while and then eventually your cane will
become weaker yeah so maybe bring the
queen back to D5 in this position to
kind of keep some pressure yeah I like
centralize the queen and then you have
to figure out what you're going to do
actually you know another move that I
like in this position for white is Queen
F5 to take advantage of the slight
weakness of black skin there and then
try to attempt Bishop D3 and then enter
with the queen and you know black at
that time at that point will only have
Queen E1 check and that's just going to
be a check right although
um
yeah probably here Black's gonna play
the move Queen E5 because Queen F5 is
like too good of a square yeah so you
have to get right now but but Queen D7
yeah yeah okay
yeah actually wait maybe you're just
winning how uh queen queen D7 what do
you do no I take and go C7 right oh
right or right I can't do that right
wait
okay well you can't trade me then
that makes me happier uh maybe bishop B5
Bishop B5 and then Bishop D3 still and
you have to play like kid f8 or
something yeah because that's gonna be
check and then I'm capturing this Pawn
so you have to go away but I can still
do that I also have this check by the
way
definitely a tough position for for
costia and he will be very happy if he
can hold it there's going to be more
pressure on this game do you want to
take a look at board one just to see
let's go back and see
was played so I guess one move right
um what were we saying see I don't like
this thing that it doesn't record it
doesn't keep our analysis anymore yeah
um I think uh
I think we were saying A3 in some
position but it was the one line that we
gave was Rook D2 with the funny Rook d8
E4 but that was mostly just for tricks
obviously they're not looking for tricks
they're looking to play the best moves
in every position yeah and and black can
probably create some kind of Loft with
H6 or G6 or something and then you know
when you double up to take that pawn he
can put the Rook on the file and try to
you know trade the d-pawn for the E Pawn
that's usually what ends up happening in
a lot of tarash positions which this is
very similar to one of those although it
was more of a Catalan but A3 was played
Rook to A4 and now E4
so I guess the argument here is after
de3 Rook E3 that The Rook on A4 doesn't
have a lot of squares to go to and
that's where white Advantage comes from
but yes you're I mean it shouldn't be
very much it seems like this game is
going to Peter out to a draw most likely
I mean are we forced to take on passant
is that
I think if you don't then you're worse
right like everyone gets to play the
move Rook D3 then The Rook on A4 is
pretty bad like Bishop's like Rook D3
Bishop C6 is not such
well or even Bishop B3 followed by
Bishop takes F7 yeah yeah that's more
like it Bishop B3 and when you take
there's gonna be a discovered idea with
Bishop takes 7 in here
yeah so uh I think detail D takes E3 is
forced in a way
it should be six whoa okay well then I
am impressed
well Bishop E6 I mean I I would love to
trade the bishop if that forces the
bishop trades even if you get this
weakness here you get to play E5 I guess
white may consider playing E5 and then
who is better in this position I don't
want to take instead of E5 can I play it
F4
first sure right certainly play that
move first but um you know that weakness
your position a little bit
how much that matters remains to be seen
maybe it matters a lot yeah like your
king will be totally restricted here and
yeah and you don't get seven strength
too
I think this is definitely a good move
that it's possible Brandon may have
missed maybe not
Bishop B6 is is really tough to deal
with maybe you start with Rook D3 though
Rook D3 here
um oh this is interesting this is
certainly an interesting idea because if
Bishop takes D5 e takes D5 we can use
the fact that you're back rank mated for
one move to play rookie four next so
like Rook d8 rookie four and I think um
or so so Bishop Bishop takes he takes
idea to have no threats yeah right so
rookie four is what I was saying for
White is my idea so such that we can
take on D4 next move after you create
left
yeah I'm trying to decide which that's
why there was a pause there I'm trying
to decide which which lift I'm going to
create you know
sure
uh here
and
yeah Pro work takes d a rookie he takes
D4 right white has good winning chances
here at least better than than what will
actually happen in the game no but um
I mean I I won't take I won't take that
that end game is bad and I think he
actually this move was played already
Rook d8 is going to suggest it for for
black and then
this
this Pawn is protected
so it's going to take you some time to
get the Palm back I mean obviously you
just simply here
well I'm sure he can take on no this is
oh I mean okay it's it's still gonna
lead to a draw or something after takes
you know
I I could try this and keep two Rooks on
the board instead of one
yeah I think maybe instead of this we
can try um uh uh we can try to make some
like improving move here like F4 or
something to that effect again because
you don't have the same thing that you
did before yeah we don't have that well
I will have it eventually I don't think
I don't think this is the same movie
you're really ready for
this time I take and what is your
approach oh yeah I'm not in time for
rookie yeah you're behind a little bit
here can I take on E6 and then play F4
you could
but there's always going to be
an issue in the second rank I think even
if you get Rook D1 and take that pawn so
I definitely will activate my Rook like
rookie two or something oh if you want
to do that no no you ever exceeded oh
I'm sorry yeah yeah no Rook seats three
or even Rook C1 okay one and getting
that pawn with the Rook you really need
to get your Pawn back yeah maybe yeah it
it just seems like there's not a lot of
way to make progress no I think I think
the players will will agree on a draw
shortly in this game for sure because
black was able to keep the position
solid maybe he was slightly worse at
some point but once the the
um
once the queens were traded off the
board there wasn't so much to to do
let's check out some of the other games
going back to elston's game we actually
saw in the break that elshon's position
was quite bad
around here when we after the castle
right yeah life had to play some A6
King h8
we were saying right and then at some
point some A6 but he played it a little
bit he kind of wasted a little bit of
time to bring his Rook on the g-file to
attack
and now
what's pieces have gone back in the game
yeah this Knight in E4 is going to be
very unpleasant keeping pressure in F6
being brought towards D6 is going to
certainly be very annoying so Bishop f8
and then
um
here
and the position is quite balanced do we
still think it's balanced because it's
been a while they've made quite a number
of moves since we last look at this game
Queen B1 he's trying to keep pressure in
G6
to keep the queen there and
so Pawns in the center are usually like
pretty strong but I think in this case
since white has all the pawns controlled
you can't play F5 because I'll take it
you can't play E4 because I'll take it
so
um yeah if anything maybe white is for
white is for Choice here instead of
instead of black just because of the
light weaknesses in the center
so it seems like Darius has tried to
somehow get control to try to play E4
but
but Alston is trading that bishop and
now I'm liking the queen in E4 it's hard
to get it away from there and it's
possible that White's Bishop is much
better than this one unless you manage
to push F5 which there's some classical
rule right you prefer to have your
Bishop on the opposite color of your
pawns and when your opponent has a light
Square weakness you want to trade the
light skirt Bishops which is what we've
done with Wyatt seems pretty nice so
although both players have quite a
number of Pawns on the same color as
their Bishops it seems that this bishop
actually
at least has the opportunity to go for
an attack whereas Black's Bishop is
totally restricted by both his own pawns
and White's chain of Pawns here on the
queen side
so Rook G8 and then
um the Ruby's coming in
A4 okay I was thinking more like some
ideas with rookie 4 but
again I'm thinking aggressive ideas for
some reason the position does not
necessarily require an attacking idea
but this could work
also some at some point if the queen
moves say queen H5 we could also bring
this Knight
to F5 which that would look really nice
yeah right
I would be a little afraid of allowing
Euphoria but if that doesn't work then
that looks really really good
so why did elshon play A4 here because I
don't know that he wants to play B5
maybe he does yeah maybe he does maybe
he does want to play B5 and take
advantage of the difficulty of black
moving that night then I would have to
go to ba which is not super inspiring
and then Queen D7 and then Rook to C1
and
he allows the queen trade interesting
because she's thinking if you trade
trade
this bishop is still quite bad
these pawns are somewhat blockaded and
we still have our idea of B5 and then C6
yeah I think and games are really bad
for black I think a lot of blacks
um positional Advantage advantages
revolve around White's King being
potentially weak
and I think Queen takes Queen takes F5
is not is not too Black's advantage
I just turned on the engine for a second
to see if A4 was really a move
and it says H4 would have been a move I
did not consider H4 I I would be scared
to we can make computers even more
aggressive this is more aggressive that
that's crazy it's crazy to believe I
thought I was being a little bit over
optimistic I've always position here but
um okay so Knight F5
okay well without the Queens on the
board
unless black manages to push these pawns
forward it's it's quite a solid position
for right definitely more pleasant as
you said
so hopefully
um you know
we'll see what happens they didn't trade
the Queens yet this is the current
position after okay to see one do you
want to uh go to the Escalante game yeah
that game
lots of things happened here white is
trying to push for
her we thought there would be some
attacks around here
but this was a big mistake by black
capturing in C2 because now White
started having ideas with the activation
of the rooken 7th rank putting pressure
in G7
Queen D6 was played and Knight E4
and I like this position we we both like
this position for white we thought the
trades of the night would be
um
in White's favor yeah but
but it seems that black was able to
trade the Queens but they lost a pawn
however D3 Rook D1
could white have traded the Queens here
in D4 probably he thought there's no
need to because now this Pawn is going
to be lost
so how did Black I see so black play
Rook D4 and now you don't have time to
go rookie one and protect that one you
need to to decide with which Rook you
will capture and he thought
this this rook and I like this idea
although I would consider for for white
in this position something like Rook C7
and Rook G3 yeah that's that's what I
was thinking too I was attracted to that
idea myself I suppose black was
intending yeah something like Rook G4
yeah and if you go here first then
a rookie seven could be played to cover
that pawn first and then keeping somehow
The Rook active and finding the right
moment to push the e-pawn I think these
positions are really deceptive like
black might think oh I'm just down one
Pawn but the thing is is that your cane
is so far away from the Apon that it
could it could actually matter and white
could generate two out two outside pass
pawns which means there are zero K N
Pawn endings that you can play
so that is true that is true and the
king is close enough to stop that E Pawn
so
yeah and it's just one it's just one
pass Pawn for for black
so white chose to keep the two Rooks on
the board and cover the the G2 pawn and
now he will still have the ability to
get the Rook active he only went to C6
with the same ideas we had earlier I
guess you thought this move will be met
by rookie seven and a pair of Rooks will
be traded or not I don't think I mean
you can maybe six years yeah king of six
and then then work C6 or E6 Maybe
but I think black's going to have a
really tough time defending this
position maybe we start by bringing our
cane like King C2
King C3 try to play Rook C4 trade that
drug and then get the king to B4 grab
that pawn and
that's a visibility yeah maybe start
with rookie too at some point to make
sure that Rick ba check doesn't doesn't
win our B2 Pawn right
this is the current position
um Brian has chosen the sixth rank
instead of the seventh
so what do we do after rookie six
because I'm not I don't think we should
trade this Rook is quite well placed
here to restrict our king or Rook to get
to the A4 Pawn I think white is planning
to keep the Rooks on the board maybe
Rook F3 check could be an annoying
decision here although you could play
look F6
maybe you have to play Rick F6 because
Kenny 7 Rook seesa oh wait actually cg7
is defendant so maybe you can do this
well do you want to have the king here
Tina is kind of weak it's a little bit
tricky this row can can go both ways
through through D3 or from behind as
well you kind of have to stay with the
rook in G4 to protect both Pawns
and maybe white will be able to combine
their two Rooks to have some
unpleasant
checks
yeah like if you got Rook F7 there you
would be threatening Rook A6 which wins
a rook which would be which would be
nice because Rook F7 King D5 or D7 and
The Rook would take the E6 Rook black
would be unhappy
true
well the line is possible that it will
go the way we suggested because in this
position black played rookie 6 this move
has been played
do you want to check up on our board one
just in case something is yeah
but um
it's really really good for white it
seems like white is on his way too
connected he has also way more time if
we check the time
difference here 15 almost 16 minutes for
white and two minutes for black H5
yeah these pawns seem Unstoppable
maybe you have some idea with H4 but
I mean what happens if I take it also
yeah I mean
I mean think black has much with that H5
it's probably just a loft idea
let's go back to board one
the Bishops got traded in the end so
Rook d3o's blades Rook d8 trades Rook C1
yeah I mean honestly I know it looks
like really Josh and it probably will be
a draw but I think Brandon is playing
for a win like I think yes certainly
yeah I'm not gonna I don't think he's
given up like quite yet like Rook C1
indicating Rook C5 is going to be really
interesting to see how he decides to put
pressure in this position
um even if there's
uh it seems like there's not a lot to
play for and black does have some minor
weaknesses he needs to attend to
Rook C6 was played King F7 and E5
so now white is not allowing black to
get this move E5 and connect their Pawns
and he doesn't Rush with F4 because you
know in some situations she would have
risked getting his skin cut off on seven
on second rank
yeah I would but this also could be a
weakness right because we could play
Rook here now yeah probably he will play
a fourth year
and then Rook B5 Maybe
oh boy I'm not sure what he's playing
are we gonna give away he's gonna give
up he's giving up the pawn yeah I'm sure
he's giving out the pawn
checking up three and he's trying to get
yeah Rook H2 then you go Rook B3 maybe
first would be three and then we play
for checkmate yeah if you if you come
here there's gonna be some mate here
with G4 or something well
remains to be seen let's
let's look for a second here so yeah
um so E5 was played in the game that was
the last move or yes
so actually here you know
you know three but we also have this
check where do you go with the King if
you go here I'm planning here oh
and F5 G4 yeah
or even wait wait actually I said that
but Rook takes G7 I just realized
threatens too yeah you can't stop both
G4 and Rook G5 that's even worse yeah
just resigns
so things could things could definitely
still happen in this game
include five interesting choice
interesting choice of keeping some
winning ideas of life
so Rook D5
and four what about G5 would this be too
much for black or is he creating more
weaknesses because I'm thinking if you
go F4 then that one is going to be weak
and obviously nobody will ever meet me
with G4 you have to be careful so I'm
sure that you have enough counter play
but Rook F3 and then Rook F6 you have to
be
where I guess you go King G7 here right
now King E7 why not okay seven Rook F6
and then you gotta be careful yeah
and then I'll go Rook D6
and then take on D7 oh I can't play D2
okay I'll I'll take here
yeah I guess
yeah the game becomes really sharp like
I take over D6 and then go F4 you know
and this position obviously requires
like a great deal of calculation at five
and F6 common
it's hard to hard to say that's hard to
say what's happening indeed
because yeah we don't want to allow F5
but I don't really have a way to stop it
if I go here at five anyways and yeah
before I have to go Keen H1 which really
sucks but you could do that first and
now maybe I can go Rook G5
so that I'm keeping the options six
and now
I'm just gonna go here Rook D7 can I go
here can I go for this one even F7 is is
no no no I have this okay let's see
yeah F7 and then after Rook F5 E6 then
D2 gets played
oh yeah so yeah okay this this seems
black black should be black should
be fine here this is not winning
I think it's a draw
yeah yeah it's a draw no I I forgot you
can take there luckily you can take
there so we're good yeah but obviously
this was this was a long way off and
it's right but it was played similarly
to our suggestion because here Rook D5
was played and then F4 and G5 so similar
to how we said it just I wanted to play
G5 first I guess he's playing G5 now
it's probably going to transpose to our
line here because
um
obviously you can't take because that
would allow two connected pawns for pass
pawns for black which you might not be
able to get anytime soon so you have to
bring in the king I think yeah and it's
going to transpose to our line what
would be very interesting no it's not
because you had Rook F3 check that's how
it is yeah so he avoided that by going
over D5 first but it would be very nice
for us if we could just play Kane from
G1 to B3
bam yeah goodbye Rook yeah then we would
then we would be pretty happy that would
be very happy but um
I mean you know what
that's that's my uh that's my new plan
after uh
two Okay YouTube
and hope for the best right we had
another result on board nine it's
actually surprising to me to see we did
not get the chance to look at that game
but Fidel Corrales lost against
International model master
gleb dudeen
so somewhere around here
white played this one of Rook D2
so the position seems quite balanced
definitely more
in Black's favor
not really quite balanced black has an
extra pawn and
these pawns seem menacing
yeah it looks pretty nice Rook D2
allowed for D4 and now you cannot really
take the pawn
and after Queen F4 D3 was played and
you're struggling with the weakness of
the back rank some pieces hanging I
think he probably just missed that right
he probably just thought D4 is
controlled twice and then he missed it
you can't capture with either piece you
can't take with the Knight because
you'll lose your rook and you can't take
with the Rook because you'll lose your
knight I think he probably just missed
you probably missed that by playing
group D2 because in this position he had
that square controlled and it's very
easy to miss this Knight D4 probably had
to be played here
even there's this idea unfortunately it
does not work maybe later with Queen A3
it would be nice if it worked but
unfortunately after Queen takes this
this looks uh districts hanging and that
Knight is not hanging so you can't
you can't defend that's why I feel that
white play Rook D2 for that idea and
then he forgot that this stuff just
happens yeah
for Fidel
um I think uh I think we're gonna go on
a short break and uh you guys should uh
definitely tune back in to see if
Brandon can generate more winning
chances against uh Yasser quesada Perez
will be sent back soon
the St Louis chess club's 2023 chess
season launches in March for the second
annual American Cup world-class Chess
Masters will gather in the chess capital
of America St Louis Missouri to compete
in a double elimination tournament for a
combined three hundred thousand dollars
in prizes we will cover all the action
live from the World Chess Hall of Fame
from March 17th through March 26th tune
in for the best game in chess streaming
live for more information visit
uschesschamps.com
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
awesome
foreign
[Music]
thank you
the St Louis chess club's 2023 chess
season launches in March for the second
annual American Cup world-class Chess
Masters will gather in the chess capital
of America St Louis Missouri to compete
in a double elimination tournament for a
combined three hundred thousand dollars
in prizes we will cover all the action
live from the World Chess Hall of Fame
from March 17th through March 26th tune
in for the best game in chess streaming
live for more information visit
uschesschamps.com
[Music]
thank you
hi everyone we are back
with the final round of the San Luis
super Swiss event we may have
only one winner we don't know yet what
do you think you mean is it possible
yeah very possible very very possible
um yeah I am National Master Julian
poleko and this is women's Grandmaster
Savannah we skipped the introduction
because we thought you guys
know us by now but if you're just
joining in welcome we are doing
commentary for the final round of the
San Luis super Swiss and
the action is
still going in this tournament and
tomorrow another event is going to start
the American Cup and we keep putting
these promos of the tournament so we
hope you guys will join the team
and check out the event route for your
favorites
it starts tomorrow Friday March 17th at
1 pm central time so hopefully you'll be
there but until then we'll have to wait
and see if this tournament is going to
give us a soul winner or multiple people
sharing first place before the break we
stopped around here and we said after G5
if the trade in F4 is going to happen
black had some chances to draw the game
but
black played G4 it's it's all about
Brandon right now Brandon is definitely
making Black's life very difficult and
if he manages to win this game he will
have soul first in this tournament with
a six thousand dollar uh finish and um
maybe some of the other players will uh
will regret not fighting a little harder
on uh on the second and uh the second
board and down
that's right yeah G4 was not a move
we're considering in this position for
black maybe
um yeah sir Casada Perez thought he
would have some entrances with the King
this way but he had those entrances even
if he took an F4 so this move was
definitely a shocker to me when I saw it
played and then Brendan
is bringing his other Rook to B7 having
some mating threat ideas or just
capturing this E6 pawn and bringing his
second Rook into the game taking
advantage of the fact that black cannot
really activate the stroking A4 King E7
was played this oh that's very
surprising to me I don't know and scary
too because
after King E7
you're basically giving away the
opportunity to go Rook B6 and grab that
bond with check
yeah and you're not like getting active
because one of the scary things I don't
know um what movie would play for for
black but if if we were to move again
like what would a past movie be like age
six or something uh White goes Rook B7
King G6 and we take the E6 Pawn but then
Black Goes can F5 and at least here
after Rook F6 kd4 it seems like black
has some form of activity with like D3
D2 coming in yeah I mean even if
objectively this position is lost you
need to be very precise with your
calculation to make sure I agree yeah
and we were mentioning earlier when E5
was played we're mentioning that G5 had
to be played because we thought the
trade had to happen so the fact that
black didn't take there at all it just
seems very surprising to me because now
he could risk of losing this position
after Rook takes E6 King D7 can't why
just check and take and
what would be the evolution of that it's
a very very strange to me yeah take take
and then take D4 it does seem pretty
good for for white
I guess his idea actually I don't even
know what his idea is because taking the
H Pawn can't be good right like you take
and then I'll take the a pawn when uh
like here if you go Rook A2 can E3 and
then takes on H2 II F5 F5 seems really
good yeah to bring the king and F4 keep
the spawn protected really really bad
right yeah it does
I have the feeling that Brendan can take
this home after King D7
if the Rooks get traded I mean obviously
there's this other idea as well that's
possible with Rook H6 trying to go there
and play for the back rank mate
now and black has quite some no he does
not have that much time he must have
spent his time because he had around 15
minutes somewhere here he did so he
spent quite some time after G4 he
probably after G4 he probably realized
that he's made a huge mistake because
now he Allied he allowed White's Rook to
get active and now this D3 move doesn't
really work anymore because
where are you gonna go with the King
well or even King E3 was no kingy 3d2
yeah actually I don't know how clear
like again Rook B7 King King G6 and then
I don't know how easy this is for for
white to be honest with you
well I don't need to play them off just
yet I could just play here first oh
that's right D2 I have this check and if
you go here there's a little mate over
there and then if you go here we have
this made so you know this is the right
moment to play King E3 and black doesn't
have any way to protect the pawn so
that's gonna be an idea missed by
yasu quesada and he thought he would
have King F5 but he might have missed
this in between move he probably thought
this was going to happen and he had some
activity as you mentioned earlier
but yeah now
he spent he spent about 10 11 minutes on
this move and
yeah he might come to regret his his
prior his G4 G4 you know does not G4
seems like a like the move that you
would play If you're trying to play for
a win yeah but in that position
yeah I agree
oh this this has happened even so all of
all of this has happened but don't you
think this is better for white
I mean what he did also seems really
good like if you can simplify to like
just I mean we got to that position with
that five and you agreed that that was
just like over right and I think Brandon
is trying to go for go for that position
it just seems easy right Rook takes D4
okay this check does not need to be
given because you don't want to allow
the skin to get active so maybe we can
try
I don't even know here
if you check we go here
is this an option maybe a rook F6 first
and then E6 I don't know
um the only problem that I'm having with
that move is that you allow the skin way
too active and I don't know how you plan
on can you one I don't I don't you're
not scared I mean I am scared but I'm
always scared I can do one so
you're just gonna I'm gonna pretend like
my my pawns matter more than than the
mating threats at the moment like
if I get my next move if you don't go
rookie two I'm gonna play Rook F7 well
I'm I'm deciding if I'll check it first
you know because this that is an option
yeah Rook F Rook f8 is my next move I
think if you go there I'll go F5
what
Rook Rook Cafe
after anything I think
This is complicated complicated stuff
yeah for sure
I feel that black should have something
here
I I'm not convinced I think that white
should be winning here to be honest it
just seems
good
um my move was not played anyways uh age
five was played in this position by
black
he's trying to keep all his pawns on the
board I guess it makes sense but but I
really like that idea I mean I really is
that really winning
can I not have something to
tuition
I'm trying to find something actually I
found an idea
um I do have another idea here this I I
know a funny study that I can show after
this
um but there's this move oh and I was
just gonna because because there's
nothing here uh I don't know if you want
to bring up like
um in uh an analysis board or something
or I think it's gonna mess up I don't
know I don't want to mess up there's
there's a study that has like a similar
idea maybe can you add a new chapter I
could but it's going to mess up
everything if I do it okay if you tell
me the position yeah so if you clear the
position pawns on
um G3 or sorry H3 and no no black pawns
Pawn on H3 Pawn on uh G4 and then
there's uh Keen oh sorry Keen is on
G8 black or white uh black and then Keen
is on
G6
and then here The Rook is on F1
[Music]
uh sorry actually upon on upon on G3
yeah Pawn on G3 once yeah like this so
it's uh
it's white to play and draw here uh I
think this is actually a little later
but this is the exact thing and it's
Rook apparently I have any address here
but like rookie I'm sorry I'm sorry I I
didn't mean to I had that open yeah the
idea is like Rook A1 you go Keen f8 Keen
F6 Kini yes yeah yeah so you just kind
of repeat that and at some point you
can't yeah at some point you get here so
then you give a check oh no sir I messed
up okay sorry the pawns are on G2 and H2
okay my bad just imagine them there yeah
and then because G1 would be check if
you go to B6 with your king but here
there's King well but anyways you
wouldn't have made if you went to B6
right
yeah yeah even if yeah you didn't have a
thread so he could push yeah um so you
could try some idea with this in The
Branding position where like Rick B1
sometimes this happens and then I don't
know if you yeah and then Rook view one
yeah but there was a study similar
fashion that actually the Kings can
march on this side of the board too I
don't remember how that one is but yeah
it is this it is this position just with
the pawns on G2 and H2
um
okay yeah
so by the way we have a result
did win his game against Aram hakobian
and if we check we left it off around
here somewhere where we said that white
white extra Pawn should definitely be a
decisive factor in this game and it was
indeed because after Rook C8 Queen E7
the game didn't last much longer because
this H5 Pawn didn't get to attack or do
anything these pawns are very dangerous
once they start pushing and
pushing happened Rook takes F5 look at
this nice idea takes and C6
these two pawns are stronger than those
two Rooks there's no way to stop those
Pawns
C7 Rook E8 and now Rook to C1 and
um
another sacrifice you know nice
Sacrifice by mihail Antipolo I don't
know if we can get an interview with him
or not maybe he already left the playing
area we're still waiting
um a lot of the players are probably
tired some of them may have to go no
matter what we're really hoping to get
an interview with Brandon yes yes of
course of course that game is definitely
Wonder looking at and we're staying
close
yeah I love this like yeah dude all the
things are hanging Rook D1 and if you if
you look at the uh the pieces on the
board right now we have a pawn and the
bishop for the queen so that's quite
interesting they're dominating the queen
because those pawns are really close to
promotion and then you know Rook D1 they
say that two pawns on the sixth rank are
worth a rook what are two pawns on the
seventh record well maybe a queen now we
find out and I guess he took the queen
now and rook d8 and this the promotion
of this Pawn is is impossible nice win
by Michael congrats on this win and
we'll have to wait and see whether he
will share the lead
we'll share the first place or not
depending on Brandon Jacobson's result
there was this game also that was quite
interesting between
Brian Escalante and durability
and quite a number of moves happen since
we left off around here in this end game
the king seems to have gone to G6 and
then
um
yeah by the way everybody that we're
looking at right now really hoping that
Brandon doesn't win I
said that's how it works you know at
some point your friends friends but once
it's about money you know yeah we have
been saying in Romanian language that
you know
cheese costs money it must be some
expression in English similar to that
too
yeah that's that would be the word by
word translation you know so you know
when it's about something serious I
don't know if we're friends anymore I
don't want the best for you which is
kind of sad actually but you know
just how it is
life life is unfair
sometimes maybe you should have said
that now because I'm getting I'm gonna
get into some controversy here I'm
better I like what Brian's doing he's
he's basically just passing but like
Black's position keeps getting worse
like every
um everything's perfect so you don't
need to change anything like the cane
stops the Canon D4 stops the canine F5
from coming in as you've pointed out the
pawns on G3 and H3 are Point are
stopping the black can come from from
coming in uh through the king side so
just Rook G2 E2 and black is eventually
going to need to make a choice of when
he's going to play the move E2 he's kind
of a nazoo here actually yes so now it's
a matter of how you get him I think
after this move isn't black like totally
in zuk Swang or does he have a check and
back but this is how you get human
zucchzone so if he checks you you come
here he comes here oh King D4 triangle
triangulation that's nice yeah and then
you'll have to go G4 which you know will
be met by H4 most likely
for sure
and um actually well the king could move
but then but then if this King moves
back white king approaches this Pawn if
you put in G4 somehow then you're going
to lose one of your pawns you're going
to lose E3 or G4 maybe both
once that happens I think yeah I think
black is totally busted right
not to say the black is busted here but
that position would be pretty bad
and some moves got played Rook takes you
three what what
triangulation idea come on
come on I thought that was a nice idea I
know why didn't he go for it is this is
this an option too but I mean who cares
I can't see four oh he has this move I
mean rookie three why isn't this like a
better version of what he did if
well yeah because the king is in C4 is
closer to there maybe it doesn't matter
maybe the King was here because you have
this check okay maybe
okay but he could have tested his
opponent and get that position
um yeah obviously you have to go King D5
to restrict the skin you can go there
because you would let this King to enter
and then it's not clear who's winning
anymore yeah who's playing for what yeah
so rookie three Rook takes G4 G4
he's surprising me with every single
move
yeah G4 is very interesting I guess
yeah I'm I'm not sure what his idea is
me neither
um maybe he wants Rook C3
and then King C5 or something
but you will always allow this wait why
would he play G4 it doesn't seem natural
at all cut the king
cut the king first just restrict it
first is he worried about this kind of
idea maybe that's why he pushed G4 but
you can play G4 afterwards yeah
no I agree with you it's um
I mean it is interesting I mean Brian's
obviously a really good player so
I definitely I definitely want to know
but he doesn't have time that's awesome
yeah he does have 30 seconds it's tough
to Play It Again Games just by intuition
if you don't have time
to
so in the game the game preceded King F4
Rook C3 King G3 we actually guessed it
correctly so his idea was Rook C3 and
then
um or wait no no no no he played rookie
four okay ah so he wants to take the G5
Pawn like this but you can't right like
Rook
b52.4 also thinking yeah this should
know this is this is a and g Pawn if I
get the king in front it's gonna be a
draw depending on how we get it yeah I
don't I don't think that Brian's going
to win this game anymore unfortunately
for him
which is also important yeah I'll put
the intro for a second to make sure like
am I seeing ghosts because it's possible
that I am but was
oh
my idea was wrong
oh because uh my idea was wrong that's
well good that I checked it okay yeah
keaney four is a really nice move here I
forgot about that okay so he saw
correctly good so I apologize chat about
that okay so but but what about the Rook
F3 thing
of the game let me just go back I just
want to make sure yeah here
see a G4 G4 sort of got rid of his
winning engine yeah Lucas three was the
move to keep some chances alive but G4
oh that was a nice idea the one that I
missed with with the king24 I saw that
idea I just didn't think it was possible
at that point right yeah we did point
that out in some other position
um so yeah probably this one's just
going to wind down to a draw do you want
to check back in on Brandon yes yes wow
okay okay lots of things lots of things
um so he
allowed
King U2 black a lot can you two so this
was Black's idea and trying to trade you
know when you have material disadvantage
in a rook end game so one Pawn down two
pawns down you try to trade as many
pawns as possible and get yourself into
a theoretical position that
um he you hope is going to be one of
those drawing ones like you know the
Philly door or vancura with the long
side or sorry not Lucena with the long
side or or the Vancouver position with a
with an A or H Pawn so he's sacrificing
this Pawn if now he's able to win this
Pawn somehow or these two pawns it's
gonna be easy draw also positions with
it's a tough ask
or somehow getting this two pawns or
these two pawns and staying with f and H
those are possible I have the feeling
Brandon is gonna guard the F and E pawns
with his life there are no Pawns
I understand I understand for
they are trying to get extra time didn't
they repeat three times now just two
times King G2
uh that repetition happened for both
players to get a little bit extra time
to calculate through things and you
would see that in a lot of Grandmaster
games or pretty much anyone can do that
of course when you don't have lunch time
left and there's an increment definitely
repeat the position but make sure it's
repeatable like the opponent actually
has to repeat because oftentimes they
see people I've done I've repeated too
many times though sometimes oh no and
then my opponent claims to draw it like
I was repeating for time I know and then
yeah and then they're like draw and then
one time I got lucky in the U.S
Championship
um a few quite a number of years ago I
was playing Jennifer you and I had two
pawns down but it wasn't clear how she
could progress in that end game she had
to make a trade eventually she she had
like an e and G and H Pawn and I only
had a g pawn and she had to play some H5
and get into that position with you know
the night Pawn that she would enter with
the king in front and she should be able
to push that pawn forward but somehow
she kept repeating to get time and when
she finally realized that she could play
it I had repeated the position three
times so I claimed the draw it wasn't
like three moves back to back repetition
oh yeah but it was the position so yeah
she hadn't realized that you feel really
smart when you do that too right you're
like yeah like repetition of move 45
move 50 and move 60. you know something
like that it was yeah
realized but you know you know verify
the Arbiters verified and you know I I
got the draw which was of course a great
save for me because I should have lost
that game in the end so King is six
yesterday so H5 and yeah so the point of
H5 H6 is you can't play any of the
positions with Rook takes F4 ever yes so
well anyways you couldn't because that
one would just go but well
but the a pawns also so you I don't know
yeah sure you'd have to you'd have to
calculate a little bit but definitely
now you can never ever ever need to get
that H Pawn and it's not easy oh but
look at that look at that one pong gun
okay but Brandon has done some
calculation yeah yeah
so
ouch okay so this is going for a win
potentially here
because he still has the H2 Pawn if you
didn't have that there might have been
some chances for a draw but he still has
the H Pawn so this is going to be
difficult
for black to save
it's going to be a long game we'll have
to
to see here The Rook has to go somewhere
back and cover
yeah
um I think that this should be winning
for sure should be winning for white I
think the pawns are too far up
yep yeah
if the spawn was in G7 you could have
made a draw all you had to do is put the
Rook back and forth again you can lose
the a pawn but it was all this line
forcing earlier did Black have to get
into this
I think of the pawn Warren F7 it would
also be a draw but if the Pawn's on F6
it's a win there's like a Zone with
these with these end games
when so um in the final like position uh
you were saying that if G7 yeah G7 F7 is
also a draw but F6 is losing yeah F6 is
losing because somehow the queen gets to
h a yeah from behind it pushes you
forward with the King and that's not
gonna go very well I actually had to do
that in a game I did succeed but I had
yeah to win I had that exact game
managed to play Queen h8 versus a
computer it's impossible to win queen
and I mean not impossible but really
hard to win queen versus Rook but
against human somehow it's a lot easier
so this remains to be seen but it seems
like Brendan may take home this
tournament if he wins this game right
and yeah I mean then Roger hardship will
definitely regret his decision to repeat
he definitely had a much better position
here towards the end after Bishop H3 he
could have played F5 and then Queen C6
and have still pressure on his young
opponent but they accepted a draw by
repeating the position with Queen C6
Bishop G2 Queen C7 Bishop H3 and that
game ended in a draw so at this point
the result of this game doesn't matter
for first place I mean obviously white
is still going to try to find some way
to
can we take
uh
oops okay he could he decided he
couldn't I'm just asking because I feel
that we could that's like right on time
right you don't yeah do you get me a
restricted because the king is too far
away I I think this is this should be a
joke I think you're fine yeah queen
queen and the king is too far away I
mean you have one check obviously you
can't give a check on on third rank due
to G3 so here but it should be fine you
can't bring in the king because the
screen comes out so this would have been
a draw but he went photograph three okay
probably also just a drop yeah because
you you're you're okay uh I actually I
like this way better in a way because
like you can just keep cutting like Kate
rookie three here well I don't know like
and now I play Rook at four wait a
second
now it's like who's playing for what
again yeah I know I know
gonna take a while it's 2600 Grand
Masters tricky in this rook and two
versus crooked one they try to win with
the rook and one don't don't touch this
Queen by this Rook uh enough for by
mistake oh no that's interesting
Rook G3 and then okay well why didn't he
try Rook F4 he could have played on I
would have played on if I were black
before probably yeah and
then I would take I don't know
but you don't wanna you don't risk
anything here you're still not risking
luckily but yeah
unfortunate for
um for Brian Escalante but a nice Save
By by this if nevertheless
so if we go back into this game to see
the blunder so the blunder most likely
happened around here somewhere
Brendan kept pushing I mean it was quite
equal yeah slightly very slight
Advantage for white and he just
um it kept improving he didn't rush with
the trading of a pair of Rooks he kept
he he kept both Rooks on the board so he
had mating ideas and
um
so somebody in chat says I bet Hikaru
would beat all these players I have a uh
I would say Hikaru would be the favorite
in each individual match-up but kikaru
is not beating every player in this
tournament they're too good I feel like
someone's gonna keep that and then
you're gonna be puts you know on a video
there's gonna be a video with you
because I think or is not and then he
got his gonna be like I don't care what
Julian said I would beat everybody
well if your car wants to prove me wrong
he's invited to next year's Super Swiss
if you would like to go 9-0 and prove me
around off of all for that inviting Cube
this is the official invitation
um but you guys will have the chance to
see Hikaru in the American Cup which
starts tomorrow 1pm central time let's
roll that intro guys if we can
that was totally they I caught them
totally unprepared
oh so we can talk over this so here's
the American Cup guys 2023 16
competitors are going to face each other
in a double elimination bracket
tournament it's a very interesting
format what do you think
I love Double Elimination Brackets it
makes it really exciting and it's pretty
fair because if you lose in the first
elimination bracket you can still come
back through the losers bracket and face
the winner at the end of the tournament
yeah so you have double chances to win
but if you
um if you won the tournament well if you
won your winning bracket so you
basically want everyone you still have
to face someone who's been given a
second choice to their Titan so you
could actually lose it I think you
played double matches though if you if
you're the winner of that elimination
bracket and then you play against the
one who comes from the losers bracket
then you have a second chance there's
going to be another match right you have
to lose two yeah or to win two in order
to actually win the event so very
interesting uh format and it starts
tomorrow with some of the strongest um
American players definitely a tournament
to look forward to I can't wait for that
tournament actually uh got the T-shirt
of the event I'm wearing it who's your
pick for for both events oh no why did
you have to ask that live I wasn't
prepared to answer
I'm being told whom to say but that's
not my choice all right
um actually in the in the man in the oh
I should say on the overall section did
he say right
in the overall section I think I'm
rooting for
oh there are two players they're really
like and it's kind of hard to but I
think I'm gonna go with
either lebronian or yeah
this is very very exciting players I
know I know I think I'm gonna go for one
of them
um I'm rooting for both hopefully they
don't get to play each other anytime
soon so they can for both as they they
can go into I didn't check the pairings
yet for sure and then in the women's uh
I don't know it's a really tough it's a
really tough call Urena is the favorite
rating wise but and she won the event
last year so but I have
I have some other players that I could
be rooting for so it's tough and uh I'd
rather not say I don't know in that
section in the women's for sure I'm
rooting for Alice Lee I root for any
Archbishop and yep I think Alice Alice
Lee has good chances this year she did
really well last year and I think this
time she's going to try to try to win
the whole thing instead of coming second
all right yeah she's had a brilliant
event last time I remember she she was
playing Arena and then she won back
um into facing her again in the finals
so that was very exciting to watch and
uh it's going to be definitely exciting
to watch this year too so guys stay
tuned it starts tomorrow 1pm central
time it's gonna go all the way till I
think March 26th it's going to be the
final the final day for that event yeah
my my picks are are Naka and Alice those
are my picks no NECA okay oh so first
you are you're giving him a hard time
that he wouldn't win but now you're
rooting for him so that's your no no no
he would he would win this tournament he
just wouldn't win every game
all right he would he would lose rating
in winning the tournament
all right
well what do we think about this yes is
Brendan going to be able he should be
able to win that g Pawn now
and this is going to be tough you have
to win it in a good way because it would
be really catastrophic if you were to
play something like Queen uh Queen E4
and then a trick for or okay not queen
queen E4 seems like a good move but if
if Queen E4 and then something or like
Queen F6 and you take on G4 with your
queen then Rook G5 and suddenly black is
Right black is back so you want to
capture that pawn with the King yeah
I've seen some stalemating ideas but
they don't quite work here say if I do
something like this but
um
I think there are many moves that that
win for
because because we captured the pawn
with check that's the problem and this
check Rook so yeah you know this is this
is an easy win yeah honestly I'm
surprised by how easy this win is
starting to look like you not only
you're not going to get king and queen
versus Keenan Rook you're probably going
to get king and queen and pawn yeah
which is a different it's not the same
level of difficulty and I have the
feeling because we had some delay in the
broadcast of the game I have a feeling
Brandon may have won already but I mean
we are haven't been told anything but I
have the feeling that he won already
this
game
hopefully an interview is on the way if
he did win seems like the result
we're confirming the result but
I have the feeling that this already
happened and yeah that would be that
would be a great win for him I know he
said
a tough time in some other tournaments
but he's definitely a
spending a lot of time on chess I've
seen him play in a lot of tournaments so
if he did win congratulations maybe it's
too early to say but yeah I think we
definitely put up a great fight oh yeah
for sure I think the first time I met
Brandon he was like this tall and rated
2000 it was World open I was like who
are you I'm Brandon Jacobson or what's
your radio in 2000 and I was like oh
yeah that's better than me and stuff
well
you know it's uh
yeah I feel that it this game is over we
haven't gotten most in a while and
blacks time has run out
so let's come up with the with the
actual blunder the final blunder that
black made in this
end game because
we thought it was going to be more or
less of an easy easy idea for him so he
played Rook D7 to avoid the checks in
seventh rank but he did allow this move
and I guess you didn't think he fight
was
was the move to play I don't remember if
we thought it was uh probably E6 and
then that pawn is going to be lost but
at least he could have taken his Rook
out maybe that was some kind of Escape
that black would have
gone for in this position maybe it's
just worth it to give the pawn to get
out who knows no apparently apparently
not yeah apparently not so King F7 was
good and just does G5 just one move one
move change yeah change the whole game
maybe you would have held against
Brandon this is what you wanted to do I
feel like I I need
I need to play a tournament soon to to
kind of
I'm finding some good moves but I'm also
finding blunder so I don't know
I don't know where my level is at this
point if I were to play an over the
board tournament I haven't played one
since
January so not long ago but yeah it's
still a few months it's almost four
months or I guess it's uh two months now
yeah
well hopefully a tournament soon for me
I'll be in the position of you know
playing my games and then my my someone
may go over them online or not we still
haven't received
any news about what Brandon did in this
game I have the feeling he won
okay all right well let's take a short
break as we're confirming whether
Brandon won this end game and we'll be
back to bring you up to speed with the
finals of this tournament stay close
guys
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back we got the results from the
final round and the standings uh yeah so
if we take a look at the results it
turns out that Brandon Jacobson actually
did manage to win that game against
Yasser quesada Perez Christopher you
drew his game against Roger harshit
elshon More diobody also Drew against
Darius reefs but really what this round
was all about was Brandon Brandon won
against the Oscar quesada Perez and has
as a result has won the entire
tournament with six and a half points
and there's a massive
um I don't even know how many uh
five-way tie for uh second place
yeah congratulations to Brendan and
let's go directly into the interview
that Jacob has with Brendan
back hello everyone I am here with the
winner of the 2023 St Louis super Swiss
Brandon Jacobson here with me everybody
Brandon tell me how you feel and take me
through your game and tell me how it
feels to be a champion yeah I know it's
amazing especially I was off to a really
bad start I drew two much lower rated
players the first day
um was not flying up to the level I was
hoping and I figured at this point you
know what like I'm not playing for
anything I'll just try to relax and have
fun with it and I think that always
takes the big weight off your shoulders
when you can finally relax and just play
For the Love of the Game I think that's
when people perform their best and yeah
I mean this game I probably shouldn't
have won all he sort of gave me a gift
but I'm definitely happy with the
quality of my play in the last seven
rounds of the tournament so it feels
amazing I just finished my games a
little shaky and from the time scrambled
but I'm sure once it sinks in it'll
it'll feel even better yeah I bet the
hearts pumping the adrenaline's still
going uh take the people you know show
them show them how you did it man for
sure yeah yeah so going to this game I
mean given the tournament situation I
wanted to push a little bit with white
but I also wanted to play pretty safe
and go for like a two years old game and
that's pretty much what I got
um I went for this Catalan line with
Knight C3 and he already surprised me
with A5 in the opening and he offered me
a draw here now trying to figure out the
way to put my pieces here because it's
not so easy so the normal plan is to
play for for you for it in some way
let's say I start with Queen D3 B6 now
E4 isn't so strong because I think he
had this this um this resource with B5
and my Center is sort of falling apart
here so I didn't love this
and if I play Slowly with something like
B3 B6
um I mean the difference is now yeah
after Bishop A6 like it's already not
supposed for me to defend my Pawn
so I thought I found a clever idea of
going Rook E1 here
with the idea being if he goes B6 now
now I'm set up to go 95 and at Bishop A6
I can take and go E4 and break in the
center before he's developed so I think
that was a little bit annoying for him
so so he has to go Knight D7
and now after Knight D2
um the point is that if I started with
Knight D2 and you played B6
E4 I think Bishop A6 again is still kind
of annoying for me because this Pawn is
pin but after Rook E1 Knight p7 Knight
D2 if B6 now I can go E4 and now that
works in E1 oh yeah and there's no pin
right exactly and I think maybe he
should he can play this anyway he can
take and go something like Bishop A6 and
it's sort of playable for him but I was
gonna go into a position like this where
I should be slightly better with my
thoughts in the center although he does
have some counter play can go for B5 or
C5 at some point
um but I think what he did in the game
was was very solid I think he was sort
of just trying to simplify it
both hope to make it dry here this is
all pretty forcing we trade everything
that F3 and okay white is a little bit
better black has an isolated pod but in
theory I mean I shouldn't it shouldn't
really be enough to win the game if this
one weakness yeah and I think he he
played pretty well for for the most
fireworks C8 take take Queen B3 I
figured my only chance because if I play
something slow like Queen D2 let's
imagine we get a position like this in
some move order
um at some point I'll set up his on B6
and Rook on C5 I'll move the queen of
double and the C file and okay he has
one weakness but I don't really see it
it feels like it's gonna be mission to a
draw probably exactly yeah yeah so yeah
so I decided to take into a queen B3
just take advantage of his weaknesses
right away but I think he made the
correct decision to just to just go
active with D4
um and the problem for me is I can't
really be greedy here like let's imagine
I I tried to take the pawn and then D3
and then all of a sudden I'm gonna
actually be in big trouble with all his
pieces are aiming at my king so I do
have to be a bit careful I can't just go
upon grabbing right away
um so yeah I plan to go Queen B5 here
just keeping an eye on the three squares
there are no tricks and still targeting
all the pawns
um but but here I think he found a
clever resource Queen F5
and it felt like white should be
slightly better here somehow but I
couldn't exactly figure out how I mean
again I can't really take a B7 because
it ripped V8
um I considered all sorts of ideas like
even even A4 here
um to try to get some position with my
Bishop on C6 I thought could be a bit
annoying for him but even if I got this
far he just doubles on the D file I
still think he's defending his weakness
pretty well and there's not really a way
for me to break through here yeah and if
it feels like maybe black might be
playing for a little bit more there
right exactly yeah so
yes I decided to take group Bishop D5
and Mark D1 which was sort of like a
safe option and the idea is that okay
this is very close to the draw but I
think he still has some problems to
solve because he does have some
weaknesses so The Logical move to try to
Simply simplify will be Bishop E6
um then I can take and take and this
idea I think is actually not so easy for
black because it's not so easy for him
to defend the pawn and after some move
by now I'm going Rook B1 and the rook's
coming to the seventh Rank and with the
two Rooks sort of hitting all the
weaknesses I think this is actually not
so easy for him to defend yeah you're
probably pushing for a win there so I
think he made the correct decision to
get a rook B4 A3 Rook A4 it looks weird
trapping his own Rook but
um I do have to defend A3 and after E4 I
think here practically he made okay
Bishop A6 is fine I mean okay here I
think Bishop D7 was the best the
cleanest defense the idea being now if I
could work E3 to defend the Pawnee is
Bishop B5 Bishop C4 sort of simplifying
um I think that was sort of the cleanest
way for him to to make a draw I think
Bishop E6 is still okay after Rook D3
but I think here practically made a huge
mistake the computer says it's still a
draw but I think here he has to take on
D5 and play something like Rook EA and
okay obviously he was afraid of working
for and and not going to win the pawn
but the second game I mean with with an
extra Pawn that's blockaded after King
E7 he really shouldn't have any trouble
here but it's King on D6 you can always
defend a A5 pretty easily and I don't
really have a way to break through here
um so I think that was sort of the
simplest way to draw it I think he
figured that probably any movie or draws
and he was trying to play the most
accurate way but after rookie um I can
take on E6 and go because okay he was
probably anticipating Rook D1 takes
takes takes and then we'll draw this is
for and then okay Miss Brooks Somewhere
um but after take take Rook C1 it's
actually kind of difficult for him now
because his Rook is boxed in and
if everyone wants to get his work out
I'll take him a few moves to encounter
and hit my pawn and by then I'm already
creating kind of creating a threats
against his King so I started with Rook
C so he goes Rook D7 because I mean if
he gives me a move to your Rook C7 I
think he's a big trouble like he has to
watch out for Rook F3 Rook F7 always
so Rook D7 Rook C6 and how E5
and yeah I mean the problem for him is
that he can't really go after my pawns
he doesn't have time because Rook B7 I
can already go Rook D6 he has to worry
about this if you imagine something like
this with check and reggae one like
already has to watch out for threats
against his King I love this okay here
this he can take this but he has to
watch out for all these ideas against
with starting my workout three check my
book just sort of was forming against
King at this point so he said that he
needs to so if he gives me a few moves
here my plan is pretty simple I'm gonna
put my king on e4 start pushing F4 G4
and break through on the king side yeah
and just start marching forward so
intuitively I think he made like a
logical Choice which is to start which
is to go G5 and G4 as quickly as
possible to to shut out my king but I
think already here he's in big trouble
after Rook B3 I'm not sure objectively
what the best way to draw is I thought
maybe he had this interesting move King
G6 here
I'm just stacking upon because if I take
it then the king gets in I have to be
careful not to lose now if he marches
his d-pawn down so I was gonna play G4
here just keeping his King out and these
lines are kind of weird like you know
King G5 I'll take
um but it feels like he should have
enough counter play to make a draw here
after takes let's say rookie six
you can go rookie seven like I can win
the pawn for example but in the end at
the end of the day like he can always
simplify all the pawns and I'm pretty
sure this is what I missed yeah that's
nice so yeah I think like he needed the
sets that now is the time he'd suggest
the epon and go for active counter play
otherwise it's going to be suffering
here because I think he counted on the
fact that my king would be kind of like
it could wouldn't really have a good way
to get in at this point and he's going
to rugby five next creating his own
counter play but I think the detail he
missed about all these lines is after
Rook B3 he's not in time to create
counter play with his d-pawn because
check King G3 up to school move King E3
and his King's just stuck in a medium
there because I'm taking Rook F6 is
basically Unstoppable
um that's pretty cool actually I think
you probably count on the fact that I
can't really be greedy because Kim will
come in and then I have to watch out for
the d-pawn but he probably missed this
King E3 resource for a few minutes back
um and if you can't go D3 then what does
he do well okay I'm throwing the Rook B7
and how did C actually get out of this
if he goes Rook D7 which is a logical
defense now I have F5 and this is a fork
and if he goes past it like this at
minimum I can play King E2 and long and
then you're just pushing the cat on F6 I
think there's no way for him to hold
this
um because there are a lot of situations
where like we get this recording with
even pawns but like you could even win
the h-man a lot of lines but with my two
connect with my past Pawn on F6 and I
always have Rook C7 rookie seven ideas
his pawn shop is gonna be like way too
slow
so Pitch Perfect King seven to meet Rook
B7 and Rook D7
um but now after Rook B6 takes
um this end game is first
and
this should be waiting for white
um but there's still some technical
difficulties because I can't really push
F5 yet because the Rook F3 check
um he started with H5 to defend G4 King
E2 now I am threatening F5 and I think
it's already not too easy for him to to
defend because the problem up for him is
that let's say he plays a waiting move
like King E6
um a cool idea a cool line is if I try
to be greedy and just push my pods
immediately my Rook is actually terribly
placed on F6 you can start with his own
counter play and keep sort of
shouldering my king and I think he'll
probably have some sort of Perpetual
check here
um
let me think I I think like
yeah let's say he just moves the roof
and where exactly do I go with my king
like if he goes if I go here he takes
again through any mate if I go this way
now he moves
and let's say rookie two to stop my epon
and then can be three to three and I'm
getting mitted so
I can't really let his King in it so the
direct one doesn't work
luckily I have this Rook D3 move to try
to get my king into the game
and even though I'm sacking each stream
I pawns are way too fast here yeah I'm
pretty sure this is winning for white
but okay I've seen how the computer says
that it's only plus 1.7 whatever that
means so maybe black has a sort of
Miracle defense but I mean we were both
already really low on time so yeah at
this point you guys were like all
playing all the increment but he did go
H4 which I think made it really tricky
after it takes Rook H3 and the idea is
he's just trying to simplify all the
pawns and the thing is I can't really
push that easily because he still goes
brick F3 and after checking six my pawns
are blockaded so I think I found a
clever move here King F2 just so that if
he ever moves his Rook off the third
ranked now I can't get sent and this
should just be winning so he sort of
Waits k6 check or pay first get some
time and then King G2 and the thing is
now you need to stop my F Pawn so he
doesn't have time to push his own Pawn
so Rook F3 Rook D4
and yeah I have a pretty simple plan I'm
just going to use my H Pawn as a
distraction for his rook and then push
my F Pawn and if his work ever leaves
the third rank to take my H final I can
also bring my king up to G3 and once my
king joins the game and joins these two
pawns it's going to be a game over so
his only chance is to keep my king stuck
on the second Rank and then blockade my
pawns so he goes E6 again just trying to
keep keep the blockade
um and now H5
and yeah the problem for him now is that
again like let's say he goes right back
to H3 check
and then H6 and at some point like I'm
going to use this Pawn as a distraction
and then my King's gonna come in and I'm
gonna stop to save him with my Rook so
he needs to keep sort of blockading my
pawns with King F5 but then I found this
cool idea which I I saw from review this
back H6 actually I think I actually need
this resource otherwise it's not really
clear how I appreciate H6 Rick H3 now
Rook D6 and yeah I mean my favorite
should break F6 and E6 so he has to try
taking and then E6 take E7 and this is a
pretty cool idea it's kind of funny like
I don't know if you do chest Tempo
tactics but you get a lot of ridiculous
like working games and chest Tempo
puzzles that I always think I'm like
okay when am I gonna need to calculate
like some crazy line in a rook end game
where you're sat yeah where you sack
your uh just like okay like I think I've
done enough please and I get this in a
game with 30 seconds left and I'm like I
know what I'm doing now I've been
training for this my whole life I've
been waiting I've been waiting so he
tries to say and what's funny is that in
this sort of end game like there are a
lot of there's some positions where my
king is stuck on the E5 and The Rook
cuts off my king it's actually some kind
of weird Fortress but with my king on G2
it's always gonna be winning
um because I can't go H3 and win queen
versus Rip but I didn't trust myself to
actually win queen versus Rich so I
found the clever idea of just belonging
him here and the point is that if you he
doesn't he can't move his Rook along the
fifth rank because I'll Fork him and he
goes to F3 I have a school move of H4
and he can't take because his Rook is
hanging otherwise Community five is
eight or if this then Queen H7 is mate
yeah that was us so he played can be
sick but now I can't get them with Tempo
and then I can reflect the pawn let's
game over man that's always a good way
to do it that's going to put you at six
and a half yeah yeah six and a half and
that's clear first six and a half for
six thousand dollars first place it's a
big bag I know you're pretty excited
about that coming into St Louis taking
home the prize feels amazing Brandon
thank you so much for coming on the show
and thank you so much for showing us an
amazing game thank you
that was that was a great interview very
very exciting very exciting interview
thanks for bringing that interview to us
Jacob and congratulations once again to
Brandon Jacobson for not accepting the
draw at move whatever that move was when
he's upon played A5 yeah and it's tough
he's playing somebody who's 50 points
higher rated his with the white pieces
his opponent gives him an easy way out
uh tied first probably at the worst case
tied first yeah and he's like no I want
to play for a win yeah and he does it
that was impressive and he took us
through the game he also let us know
because we had the question about Queen
D2 and I don't think Jacob was told that
we really wanted that answer but we got
it from Brandon congratulations once
again six and a half and winning the
event
um soul soul winner six thousand dollars
let's take a look at the final standings
uh and see where everybody ended up so
Grandmaster Brandon Jacobson of course
clear first was six and a half
uh there is a what is that
okay four-way tie uh on six points for
second place and those players are
Christopher Wu uh um Nicholas theodoru
who had to take a buy to play for uh St
Louis uh today in the protest League uh
Mikhail and teepoff and Raja harshit all
on Six Points Roger probably maybe a
little bit unhappy about his decision of
taking a draw earlier in the game where
he still had chances to press on uh the
young Grandmaster Christopher you and as
you said unfortunately for Nikolas he
had to take a bite to playing the
purchase
was not part of the pack but he won a
nice game against
um around Jacobian to catch up and share
second and then we have quite a number
of players sharing sixth place
those players
once again congratulations to Brandon
Jacobson winning first place with uh and
taking home six thousand dollars yeah
not bad for uh five uh five grueling
days he had a tough start but he came
back six thousand dollars for five days
of work not not such a bad payday that's
right um but right after this tournament
uh there's a tournament immediately
starting afterwards which is the
American Cup coming up from tomorrow
yeah from March 17th through uh 26 and
we actually have a preview as to who's
going to be playing in that tournament
and what the brackets are so for the
first time ever we will be saying uh
tomorrow in the overall section Nakamura
is playing against Savion uh aronians
playing against Dominguez so is playing
against Shanklin and carwana is playing
against Robson so if you're interested
in seeing that definitely tune in
tomorrow around 1pm and I actually felt
really sad when I just received this
message because as I was telling you
guys earlier I'm actually a routine I've
deciding who I'm rooting for aronian or
sebyen but they might be facing each
other in round two uh the time control
for that tournament is going to be
um 90 minutes but
with the 30 seconds increment and then
in the second bracket in the losers
bracket if you lose the match then you
are going to they're going to play uh
faster time controls 25 minutes
games
also it's important to note that this is
the first time we are
actually announcing these pairings so so
they are live we don't know the colors
yet for the first round those are going
to be drawn at the opening ceremony
later tonight let's see in the latest
section so we have Irina Crush facing
abrahamian
um
Guru beginner Genova is playing against
Katrina and Sova anazatonsky is facing
Nazi paikidze and Alice Lee is facing
atusa percussion so those are going to
be the brackets guys I cannot wait for
the American Cup to start tomorrow I
hope you guys enjoyed our show
um for the senator super Services it was
wonderful doing commentary with you
Julian and
thank you all for joining us on our
Twitter twitch and YouTube Pages stay
tuned for the American Cup tomorrow
around 1pm central time bye for now have
a good one
[Music]
thank you
the St Louis chess club's 2023 chess
season launches in March for the second
annual American Cup world-class Chess
Masters will gather in the chess capital
of America St Louis Missouri to compete
in a double elimination tournament for a
combined 300 thousand dollars in prizes
we will cover all the action live from
the World Chess Hall of Fame from March
17th through March 26th tune in for the
best game in chess streaming live for
more information visit uschesschamps.com
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited